good morning everybody it is
9:30 um
so I am going to open the public hearing
but we're going to have to go into
recess because nobody is here um so
before we begin if you would just all
please join us in Rising for the Pledge
of
Allegiance
okay so I am opening the public hearing
for House Bill
1038 and we will be in just a short
recess so I can try to assess our
situation
okay I'm reopening the um public hearing
on HB 1038 and invite the prime sponsor
to introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chairman honorable
colleagues it's uh it's like deja vu all
over again some of you are probably
looking at this going gez I I thought we
disposed of this uh just last year and
uh you you would be right this is the
this is the bill that this committee uh
recommended ought to pass has amended uh
and the uh the house in all its wisdom
passed it on to the senate senate took
it
up and they decided that they wanted to
do a national legislative CH just to uh
make sure there was nothing hiding under
any stone that may have been left
unturned um this is the packet it looks
thick and daunting uh most of the most
of the pages are like the first Pages
there's there's nothing there um this is
in your email as of this morning so you
can review it at your your leisure
between now and your your exec session
um that's that's coming
up I I've reviewed the information that
the the Senate oh so I'm sorry so the
Senate um
passed the bill um interim study and I
was encouraged by um the the chair of of
their committee uh to refile the bill uh
to look through this and then make any
any changes as as one may see fit I have
gone through all of this material um to
to the best of my analysis there's
nothing in this packet um that says that
this bill is is not a good idea there's
nothing in this packet that that says
that this would open up the state of New
Hampshire to Legal threat if we pass
this this bill um this is basically um a
survey of of State statutes across the
country uh Most states are are like New
Hampshire so we've got restrictions on
employment opportunities for registered
sex offenders and they basically all are
like New Hampshire right so it's for
School Employees it's for people
volunteering at uh organizations that
provide uh Direct services to
miners and we already have that on the
books that's well established the
loophole that we are trying to close in
New Hampshire law is the loophole that
allows a convicted sex offender to be
the the direct supervisor the direct
management uh over a minor
child or to to employ directly employ
minor minor children it it puts the kids
at risk it puts the registered sex
offender at risk and so this closes that
loophole I think we did the right thing
last year and I would encourage the
committee to do uh the right thing again
this year and I will go to the Senate
and uh review this packet with them and
say there's there's nothing here that
that causes us us
issues so from from my my point of view
nothing has changed I would ask the
committee to uh again recommend this
thought to pass and we pass it through
the house and and and take it up with
the
Senate thank you representative um the
bill that passed the house last year was
amended is is this the amended version
or is this the original bill you filed
last year that should be the amended
version I requested through OSS that
they pass the that they they reissue the
the amended version that we passed
through the house okay because um
several people have pointed to me that
this is the original not the amended so
want to make sure if if that is the case
that that is an error um and so I can
certainly double check that what I what
I am requesting is that we um pass the
the bill that the house passed so if if
OS gave me the original language I
apologize um it would have been a
miscommunication between them and I and
so uh if somebody would file an
amendment to make it the amended version
I would be obliged thank you
um uh Mr chairman if I could just just
say one other thing you know one of the
big um issues with this bill is the
potential that you know we're not going
to make any employment opportunities
available to registered sex offenders
and I I would contend that this bill
does not do that and I would remind the
committee that New Hampshire uh it
continues with uh the lowest
unemployment rate in the nation if not
one of the lowest so if we're not the
lowest we're we're very very close uh so
there there is a plethora of job
opportunities out there for for
everybody thank you um representative
Manning did you want to add some clarity
to that question I had yes thank you Mr
chair um so I'm holding the bill that
you filed which I looked up is the it
appears to be the original bill you
filed last year I also have a copy of
amendment number 2023 0586 that I
believe is the amendment that we worked
on in subcommittee that's that's
different than what you are proposing
Then I then I apologize that was an
oversight on my part and probably a
communication from OS I what I want is
what we passed last year so if that if
that's not that I apologize I I'll take
ownership for that that oversight I want
to pass what we amended and pass last
year that's what I'm asking and that's
what I'm I'm asking you that's the one
you that is what I yeah because that's
what we all agreed on um and and so
that's and I if that's not what you have
then I apologize that I want to pass
what we passed before can you tell us if
you recall um what the change was the
amendment did to the bill if you don't
recall that's okay we can work it out so
I I don't I don't recall the particular
details um there there was there was
just some language reworking um and it
it basically brought um the opposition
and the proponents of the original bill
um together with language that we could
all all support there was nothing
controversial um in the in the amendment
that we passed last year and I I think
that it it fully accomplishes what we're
trying to accomplish thank you I'm I'll
see that the entire committee gets the
uh new gets the amended version and one
of us will uh work with
OLS actually if you could call Os and
ask them to draft you can put in my name
I I will do that as soon as I leave
thank you questions um represent
Murray thank you Mr chair and thank you
um for taking my question you um just
kind of referred a couple times to um
potential issues the Senate saw in their
research I I'm just curious if you've
heard like concerns from them um that we
should be aware of in moving the bill
forward thank thank you for the question
um so if that's if that was your
takeaway then then I apologize because I
didn't communicate clearly so my
understanding in talking with the the
chairwoman from the committee on the
Senate was that their
committee wanted to get more information
on a nation scale relative to these
types of of laws to compare it to what
we're proposing to make sure um some
other state hadn't tried the same thing
and and found themselves in in trouble
with with the the Judiciary Branch um
because of it so you'll and the
Chairman's already sent it out this
morning so you'll receive the packet
it's not that daunting most of these
Pages have no no words on them um I've
reviewed this there the no by the the
other states um the the other states
have
never our law with this law when when we
pass it will make uh New Hampshire
uniquely restrictive in that we will
have um codified in law that you cannot
be the the direct manager the direct
supervisor of a minor child if you are a
registered sex offender um that's that's
the loophole that we're trying to close
we all agreed on um and so they they
didn't have this in a timely fashion to
be able to to work it through their
system so they that's why they voted for
uh interm study so that I could refile
look through the packet make sure
there's nothing wrong so to the to the
best of my knowledge um this should go
through this time thank you for the
question representative
Newman this I make a question to
representative Manion about the
amendment that he has whether it was a
2024 Amendment or a 2023 Amendment
2023 this is the amendment we got out of
our subcommittee last year okay and a
question to the chair may maybe if we
could just make a copy of that for some
sort of reference we could have get to
comparing the two things earlier make
make it easier yeah that's I'm going to
have um I'm going to have the the that
version sent to everybody um I don't
think that um I don't think that we need
it for questions at this point because
the changes um
and representa Manny perhaps you can
speak to the changes you were on the
subcommittee yes so if I remember
correctly there was some issues that
representative Lynn had with I believe
the owners being on the employer not the
employee there is a long list of um jobs
if you will or employer types um and if
you remember last year when
representative Muse mentioned the
longest sentence in a bill that's what
this was there's a list of uh so it kind
of narrows it down to just these these
items it was so if I remember all of the
questions or concerns that
representative Lynn had were met they
worked on this together in this amended
version and that's the one we passed
through the house so thank you for for
the sake of um brevity like I said I'll
make sure everybody gets it I'll ask um
if representative Ville could be here
for the executive session in case anyone
has any last minute questions or no is
your executive session next week it's
this Friday next week's holiday this
Friday um I will I will try my best I am
in in state um so I will absolutely try
my best okay if if you have questions
email them to me and I'll send them to
the uh representative and we'll see if
we can't get an answer for everybody um
that can't be answered today further
questions if I could just ask can you
can you give me that amendment number so
I can go get that as soon as we're
done6
0586 H thank
you okay see no further questions um
thank you
representative thank
you and the chair calls Jane
Graham good morning Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Jane Graham I
am the Strategic Communications
administrator for the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections uh I think
what we originally came to testify on um
we believed was the unamended version so
the amended version that went through
the subcommittee process we're we're
already with that so that's what we'll
be voting on so okay great do you have
anything you want to add while you're
here uh no it was just clearing up our
primary concern was clearing up direct
service to miners that was in the
original but the amended version does
provide clarification so that's fine for
us okay thank you okay great thank you
Richard chair call Sergeant Richard
perau like the ladies uh that were
before me said we were prepared to to
come today and uh testify to the um
unamended version but the UN the amended
version uh we're going to remain neutral
on that so
okay
questions he's working on it right
now anyone else wishing to testify on
this bill who has not seeing none I
hereby close the public hearing on House
Bill 1038 I open a public hearing nope
we still got 10 minutes um 10
minutes
hereby open a public hearing on house bu
Bill 1204 and invite the sponsor to
introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chairman esteemed
members of the criminal justice
committee I am proud to sponsor hb24
this bill concerns the so-called Open
Fields Doctrine uh which allows
officials in our case it's New Hampshire
officials to enter and conduct
warrantless searches of private land
Beyond what's known as the curtilage
immediately surrounding the home uh the
vast majority of private land in New
Hampshire is subject to the Open Fields
doctrine that means that government
officials currently can decide to enter
someone's private land whenever they
want for whatever reason they want even
when the property owners uh who desire
security and privacy put up fences or no
trespassing signs and
Gates HB 1204 would help fix this
situation and better protect our
property rights under it land owners can
make their property eligible for
protection against warrantless searches
by posting no trespassing signs or
similar marks of ownership if they do
then hb24 would require virtually all
government officials to either get a
warrant or get the owner's permission
before they enter the
property this is not though applying to
anybody who needs to enter the property
because of a 911 call or probable cause
that there's a an immediate need for
services or help that is addressed in
the bill and Exempted
those actions are protected so that the
you're not stopping emergency response
at all it's just saying that without
permission from the landowner or a
warrant you can't just wander into
people's woods and Fields and whatnot
uh for no reason at all they have to
have a reason and get a warrant or they
have to get permission from the
landowner overall hb24 seeks to restore
balance and ensure that land owners in
New Hampshire have the necess necessary
protections against unwarranted
government intrusion on their
property and I can take some simple
questions but I can tell you that I've
got somebody that can answer a lot more
questions in depth from a legal
standpoint that can also
testify um just if you could what did
something occur to to cause you to want
to sponsor this bill no no single action
but there has been court case perhaps
this this has been getting uh passed in
in uh several States as the situation
has become uh known in other states and
I'm not sure how many exactly but I can
tell you that uh for example Vermont has
never allowed Open Fields they've always
protected the landowner's
rights represent
PR so I know as a firefighter right now
there's an RSA if I suspect that there's
a fire on someone's land I have the
ability to go look for it you could
still do that even if it's just a legal
burning some somebody burning in a in a
can or something all right that's
protected under a probable reason to
enter the property thank
you represent Manion thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question as
far as the body Camera Part goes there's
already an RSA that covers body cameras
that I believe um is is similar to that
but there might be exceptions that are
in the body camera Bill law I mean that
might conflict with that so should that
be better left just to that RSA or I
would entertain comparisons and and make
sure that it aligns but I trusted OSS to
make sure that these line up okay thank
you as as we've already experienced this
morning that could be a questional
decision that's why I I gave that caveat
that uh I would ask that you um take a
moment and just call up that RSA just to
compare so if we need to get because
we're executing this Friday if we need
to amend something we we need to do it
pretty quick I will I will make that
comparison for you thank you um no
further questions thank
you the chair recognizes Mr Robert
frer okay not used to that thank you Mr
chair members of the committee my name
is Robert fer I'm a senior Attorney At
The Institute for justice and I'm the
director of the stute for Justice's
project on the fourth amendment and I
came up to express our support my
support for hb1 124 for really two
reasons the first one is that it's
important to understand what Open Fields
Doctrine is this is a creation about 100
years ago out of whole cloth by the
United States Supreme Court in one two
paragraph case they say no private land
outside the immediate area around your
home gets any protection whatso all
under the Fourth Amendment and as a
result in many States the vast majority
of land is unprotected here in New
Hampshire there's 3 roughly 3.6 million
Acres of private land 91% of it gets no
protection whatsoever from from entries
and what that means and I've litigated
these cases across the country I've
interviewed uh law enforcement officials
other officials who will come on
property not because they suspect
anything not because they think there's
say anything wrong but just to see
what's going on they call it patrolling
uh they'll uh in many of my cases and
several of my cases not they haven't
just walked on themselves but they've
installed cameras you know for the
remote snooping where it would feed back
to them so they'd have a 247 view of
what was going on and in one case they
did even more than that they actually
went in and stole my client's camera and
then opened it up to see what they could
find over and over again I've heard from
public officials that when with regards
to Open Fields Doctrine they really
don't make any difference
uh distinction between public and
private land and we've seen that over
and over the country and that's why hb24
is so important uh this bill is a modest
bill that is simply trying to empower
New Hampshire residents to reclaim their
security in their premises as the bill
notes you know all of what people
private land owners have to do is put up
fences or sign no trespassing signs
there's a number of different ways to
Bill allows for them to express that
they want to keep their pri property
private and when they do that and of
course some won't some will but if they
do what that means is that uh the
majority of the vast majority of public
officials will have to either have get
permission to come on the property get a
real warrant from a real judge or have a
real emergency uh like that's going on
an exigent circumstance we call it under
the law
now this is pretty modest uh a number of
states across the United States have
rejected the open field Doctrine uh uh
the representative mentioned probably
the most applicable one Vermont Vermont
wholly rejected the Open Fields Doctrine
in
1991 came back in 2018 and said again no
we really mean it private land means
private if you want to go on it get a
warrant and you know I don't think that
the people of New Hampshire view their
property rights as any less important
than the people of Vermont or the people
of New York who also have rejected the
Open Fields Doctrine and your
constitutions look almost exact exactly
the same they say they protect
possessions and land is a
possession so Washington Oregon Montana
Mississippi New York Vermont Tennessee
all these states have rejected the Open
Fields Doctrine and we think this is a
this 124 is a modest step towards
improving the security and property
rights of ordinary New Hampshire that's
why we support it but I off uh happy to
take any questions anyone the committee
might have thank you so for
clarification it seems to me what this
does is it basically treats all of your
property as your house with regard to
your privacy um so in other words unless
there's exent circumstances police can't
come into your house unless invited with
a warrant the same would then apply to
your property if you post it if you
leave it alone that's your risk to do is
that clear is that that's exactly right
and that's the way it is in that's the
way it used to be before uh the Supreme
Court issued its decision and it's in
fact the exact same way in like every
other similar country you know we're
similar to England in Australia New
Zealand none of them have the Open
Fields Doctrine we're sort of a unique
aberration That Way NE Hampshire uses um
appraisers every so many years to
appraise people's property would this
stop them from coming and doing their
job would they are they going onto
people's private onto the private
property in order to conduct the
assessment yes uh if they get the
consent of the of the property owner as
part of the appraisal process I think
there's probably abilities to condition
get you know if you give consent to do
the appraisal we'll be able to then do
the appraisal and it would be more
accurate than if we're not allowed
access to the property in which case
your your appraisal might be higher uh I
think we're going to have to check we
may have a conflict in statute if if
people are mandated to I tell you
something about that I'll let you come
up in a second then okay um we'll leave
that one for him to answer and we'll
check um my last question is regarding
um what about drones now you you're
protecting the the four corners of the
property but what about the airspace
above it that's a fascinating uh
question chair because uh I just had a
case before the Michigan Supreme Court
uh two months ago uh it's the first uh
Court in the country to consider whether
flying a drone over someone's property
is a Sur SE under the under either the
Fourth Amendment or the state analog I
think it obviously is it's invading your
you could look at it from one to two
ways from sense of property rights it's
coming right over your property it's
searching your property from inv from a
privacy standpoint it's looking at your
backyard it's looking the inside of your
house ultimately it's the government
using a technology to try to acquire
information and I would argue that when
it's doing that that has to be subject
to Fourth Amendment constraint
and that means generally unless there's
an emergency or someone consents that
you go get a
warrant but I don't but I don't think
that this bill directly addresses that
because this is this is specifically
about physical entries by agents
themselves and not about the use of
technology so I don't know I don't think
this is directly applicable to that
particular issue okay my concern is if
we decided to pass this an agent could
walk right up to the property line float
the Drone they don't cross the line and
and they could fly 6 ft off the ground
all through the properly and that
defeats the bill well I that that is a
very fair concern and you know if if the
committee wanted to uh amend this so as
to prohibit the use of Michigan for
instance has a statute that says uh
officials can't use a drone to do what
they couldn't do directly so they can't
since they can't walk on the on your
property directly they couldn't use a to
S circuit that that's some kind of that
similar language could be here to uh
protect against that uh loophole yeah
that that might be a that might be a a
too big a bite um I think that A
legislature is going to have to examine
how high above your property is is your
airspace because frankly where I live um
planes going to Manchester fly right
over my house every day is that my
airspace I mean what who know chair I I
could give you I I I know you need to
move things forward give you a
fascinating multi-hour discussion about
this this I would be interest going
forward too because it is it's growing
faster than we can legislate it and um
people's rights are people's rights
exactly um all right uh further
questions representative
rhs thank you Mr chairman I I just need
some clarification sure when when you
were given your example you had said
real war real warrants from real judges
yes what other kind of warrant and
judges are there oh no I mean but what I
mean by that is oftentimes we'll see
uh uh Court uh statutes say things like
court orders or subpoenas and what I
mean here and the language in the bill
uh handles this pretty well uh the the
definition of Warrant here talks about
uh a court order authorizing a search or
seizure that's supported by
individualized probable cause and issued
by a judge that's what I meant by it not
a subpoena where often times uh
prosecutors can themselves write their
own subpoenas so you wouldn't want to
have a situation where oh we want to
protect private land but if the officer
just writes a form fills out a form
saying he now has the power that sort of
defeats it so that's what I was talking
about represent
PR uh when I was up in
Edna we had a bunch of bills come in for
drones um uh and I know there is some
protections already in place on what law
enforcement can and cannot do with
drones without a
warrant represent Stone thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
in regards to this bill I like majority
of it I do have concerns with running uh
art section five if section five was to
be removed how problematic would that be
moving the bill forward did you State
for the committee what section five uh
section five is the government agent
equipped with a body warn camera while
entering a secured premise the camera
must be activated recording the entire
time the agent is on the premise and
basically my concern is same as
representative Manion we have a section
that deals with that specifically and it
might be cleaner to leave that section
out of the bill I I don't think that's a
material portion of the of the of this
legislation I think it's much better to
harmonize uh this with the existing
legislation rather than create a
conflict so if removing this would
resolve that a potential conflict i' I'd
recommend that I would see that as being
a much cleaner Avenue to go down thank
you um representative
Muse thanks for taking my question in in
your opinion is there a difference
between a law enforcement officer
wandering around on your property
Uninvited and a hunter wandering around
on your property uninvited
No in fact in
well no and yes no in the sense that
they're both trespassing you know the
property law is pretty clear if if I
don't have consent to enter and I do
that I'm trespassing doesn't matter what
hat I'm wearing I will say it's
different though because an ordinary
citizen doesn't possess the unique
powers of the state they you know they
can't they can't search they can't
initiate criminal proceedings they can't
arrest you can't you know legally shoot
you so like there's a unique while
privacy is important I think the
important thing is that people need to
feel secure on their property uh against
unwarranted government interventions I
agree with you that trespass is a
problem no matter what it is but when
it's an armed agent in the state that
that perks my ears up just a little bit
more thank you uh representative m is
referring to another bill that we dealt
with last week with the hunting question
um in to be clear both bills say you
have to post your land so if you post no
trespassing you could be a hunter a
police officer um a Spaceman in this
bill you cannot trespass yeah and that's
why I found so uh useful about the the
concept of secured premises that was
already in New Hampshire law and it
seemed like that was a an obvious way to
make that distinct uh
distinction represent
Newman thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um you mentioned in
your testimony that there was a Supreme
Court ruling that Open Fields
yes met the the requirements of the
fourth amendment I believe I'm adding
that um what's the what's the status of
that case was that case overturned and
does it conflict with this in any way
unfortunately is not overturned it was
it was started in 1924 the case is
called Hester versus United States so
we're on its 100th year anniversary
unfortunately I'm having a celebration
this uh spring we're running having a
conference to talk about the uh Open
Fields Doctrine and uh the various
problems with it but what states have
done a number of states like Tennessee
Mississippi uh Vermont they said well we
don't really care what the people in d
what the people in the Supreme Court say
you know we have our own Constitution
and it means what we think it means and
we know our people wanted to have this
kind of protection and so they rejected
under their state
constitutions follow follow
up so if we pass if this state were to
pass that law they would be making would
have to make the same assumption that
they just don't have to pay attention to
what yeah the what I'm a little bit
confused about that okay sure yeah what
so there's the United States
Constitution which handles Federal
officials and stuff like that
but the New Hampshire uh Supreme court
is the ultimate Arbiter of the New
Hampshire Constitution and it is
separate and distinct and even if the
fourth amendment allows Federal officers
to do something like the Open Fields
Doctrine you all have the power to say
as a matter of state law or the State
Constitution that no our state officials
can't do that so that's what that's why
I'm saying that the fact that the Hester
decision from 1924 is still on the books
doesn't prevent State legislatures like
yourselves from saying that is too far
that is too low a floor that is not I
disagree with that holding I think that
is wrong I think is bad for property
rights and I'm going to do something
more and you are perfectly entitled to
do that under the both under the
Constitution and under
legislation thank you so for
clarification now um a a New Hampshire
officer could have or ask a Federal
Officer to look at something for them
this wouldn't stop them because this
would only prohibit New Hampshire law
enforcement is that your position I
think that that would get into a if
you're having actor of the state type of
thing I I think I think I think you
would run in I think that would be an
attempt to make an end run around this I
think it would end up being a very
contested legal issue about whether the
Federal Officer was really exercising
his own independent Authority or if he's
just acting as an agent of the state
okay
um any other further questions
oh actually I I had one the the Supreme
Court has narrowed the Open Fields
Doctrine a bit though haven't they isn't
it true that they've extended the
curtilage a little bit to places that
people routinely use for example if you
have a shed that's 50 m back in your
yard that really wouldn't be in the
curtilage but if you use it and have an
expectation of pracy have they not
extended that yeah the problem there
have been some of that and it's very
Case by case specific specific the
problem is is
that it leads into because this
reasonable pardon me this reasonable
expectation of privacy oh it's this
balancing test right it's like oh well
what's reasonable and it's often very
fact specific and it's
often there's no certainty there's no
certainty with it you simply don't know
because there are courts that have said
yes that's that would be a search
despite the Open Fields Doctrine there
have been other courts that have said no
that's not a search because the Open
Fields doctrine that that kind of of
wishy-washy judicial decision making
doesn't provide people the security they
need and that's why I think this
legislation is so important just says
that in no UNC terms if you want to go
on people's land get their permission or
go get a warrant thank you uh one more
question representative Newman yeah just
just following up on your question
wouldn't that more or less be your
curtilage would that not fall within the
curtilage what you just explained just
well that's that's literally what they
say like oh well if it's a barn but if
it's closely associated with the things
you do then maybe it's part of the
curtilage but you never know ahead of
time what a Court's going to say you can
never feel secure on your property
because you don't you don't know if the
officer is going to think oh that's
kurage I can't go there and you don't
know if the court down the afterwards is
going to say it's curtilage or not so
there's no certainty and that's why this
legislation provides that security
because it just says very
clearly you post your land your land is
your land is secure go get a permission
go get permission or a warrant you don't
have to play any guessing games like you
do with current Fourth Amendment
Doctrine thank
you see you no further questions oh
representative
scitec I'm wondering whether we should
wait for the court to come in are New
Hampshire Supreme Court come in on this
and here's what I'm thinking uh we have
a constitutional right to privacy can
can you if there were such a warrantless
entry and some action resulted from that
warrantless entry could the land owner
go to the New Hampshire Supreme Court
and say I have the reasonable right to
privacy or my property I don't need this
law sorry I apologize for uh talking I
that is possible that could happen I
will be honest the reason this Doctrine
has stuck around for so long is that
most of the time people don't do that uh
they don't uh press the legal issue but
there's nothing about
uh there's nothing about the new H uh
New Hampshire Supreme Court that should
give this body any pause about whether
to act whether it is forbade as a matter
whether entries onto the Open Fields is
forbade as a matter of New Hampshire
constitutional law is a separate and
distinct question from whether this body
thinks as a matter of
policy it is a bad idea to let officers
roam wild over private land this body
has the power to fix that now and I
would suggest taking that step now
rather than kicking the can and hoping
that maybe years down the line maybe
somebody will challenge this issue while
all the while real uh New Hampshire
residents are still suffering from the
loss of their property
rights I believe the representative is
referring to a uh a recent adoption to
our constitution regarding privacy
rights however we still have in our
constitution the equival of the Fourth
Amendment so would is is it not possible
that the court would see that as
separate and distinct from the search
but since we already we didn't amend the
Fourth Amendment we we added this thing
yeah and I believe that's section 2B and
I believe the search and seizure
provision is either section 19 or
section 20 and from what I understand
about the the P the legislative history
around Tob is that it was more about
informational privacy uh I think that
the the art the search and seizure
provision of the New Hampshire
Constitution which uses the term
possessions which by all counts includes
land should already be doing this for
New Hampshire citizens it's just not but
you guys don't have to you this
committee doesn't have to wait years to
see what the court does you can take
action now to fix it represent Stone
thank you I have a two-part question the
first part is in your opinion is New
Hampshire under law as well as New
Hampshire Constitution provide a higher
bar for privacy interest in the state of
New
Hampshire could you say that one more
time other words do we set uh privacy to
be a higher bar for search and seizure
in New Hampshire States um generally uh
unfortunately I would say generally not
uh I believe that the New Hampshire
courts have I'd have to go do a deeper
dive as matter of constitutional law I
think it's uh pretty much flattened to
the Fourth Amendment standard that there
isn't a lot of there had this is an area
where the uh Supreme Court should do
more work but right now I think it's
held the two to be at equivalent level
so I don't think there's greater
protections well actually now that I say
that I think the addition of 2B probably
provides a Judicial gloss that will lead
to Greater recognitions of privacy going
forward and second part of the question
is under this uh provision of this uh
Bill if it was to pass nothing prevents
a police officer government agent from
seeking out the addition of the premises
listed here in articulable suspicion
when seeking out a warrant
wait I'm I'm in other words you if you
wanted to do the field you'd have to
articulate in the search Point why you
wanted to search the field you'd have to
say uh yeah like if it was yeah you'd
have to say you'd have to do
investigation just like officers have to
do with crimes of all other sorts you
know you'd have to provide you know when
they want to get a warrant to go into a
house or to a business or anything like
that they have to provide all the
information Pro submit a warrant and you
get approval and that's all this bill is
trying to say is let's make that across
the board and let's include private land
in that as well thank you I for my
clarification I think what he's asking
is when you get a search War for
someone's house you have to be specific
as to where you want to search and for
what items you want to search would this
apply them to the open field I want to
search in the back 20 20 yards of the
property where I suspect there may be X
and that is what I'm looking for and
that I want to search a search would
wouldn't just say you have access to the
property walk around
a core element of the Fourth Amendment
and the New Hampshire search and seizure
is that warrants have to be specific
they're not supposed to leave discretion
to the officers and so yeah a warrant in
this kind of situation would to the best
of your ability say I believe uh at this
location on the property I I'll find
whatever okay representative M did you
have a
question I had a question about how
we're protecting privacy in this bill if
we require a law enforcement officer to
have his body camera on the whole time
he's on the
property well that was mostly in the
instance well if if there's consent
right if there was consent then let me
go back I think that was the part of the
bill that uh I think that was the part
five of the bill that was uh people were
considering uh
rejecting
uh it well it's says if he's equipped
with a Bor camera when entering a
secured premises so if he's there by
consent then then the person's consented
so there's no privacy issue and if
they're there because of a warrant they
got a warrant then a neutral judge has
already decided that there is probable
cause of some violation of law occurring
such that it's reasonable to infringe on
that privacy and
so I again I'm I think I'd be fine with
Section Five being removed for the bill
and in sense of Harmony but uh I I don't
think it necessarily undercuts the idea
that people want security and privacy in
their private
land followup
followup what was the role of your
organization in the drafting of the
bill uh I helped draft the bill I helped
draft the bill uh I've spent years
working on this sort of work uh I've
read the
the legislation from across the country
the court cases from across the country
uh representative uh expressed a desire
uh to do something in this area and we
talked and I gave him some advice and we
helped him put this
together thank
you thank you trust me you're not alone
representative
wheeler thank you Mr
chairman would you believe that a person
who has a warrant going on for their
property would want whatever the police
are doing on that property to be filmed
so that they know what is happening for
the police search and that might be why
the body camera pieces in there it's
possible I feel as if I'm in a cross
conversation about this issue uh I can
see valid reasons both to not want the C
not want cameras but to want cameras uh
that that's fine we we'll we'll save
that for executive session okay uh
representative uh Newman I just have a
question about the conversation that's
going on H how does this Bill affect the
the a person who is under investigation
and doesn't know it and then the police
want to continue an investigation would
they be able to do do they have to
present a search warrant to work on any
part of their land if if they're under
investigation how does that all fit in
with this so you're saying like this
bill passes and then the police suspect
somebody of something wrong and the
question is can they enter the his land
without a warrant no they would have to
either get his consent or a warrant the
fact that he's under
investigation uh I mean that's part of
the investig getting a warrant is part
of the investigatory process uh so I I'm
not sure I
understand a question no that's
basically my question I mean I mean if
you if you if you apply the same um
requirements for a search warrant when
the Supreme Court court has already the
reason it's called open field is you
don't have an expectation of privacy in
an open field right that's what they
said so so the Supreme Court has said
that you can't expect
privacy out away far away from where you
where you live and there could be ille
legal activity out there
so and I don't know that much about
search warrants I don't know if a judge
could say and could override this Som I
don't know no well he could issue a
regular warrant saying I think there's
probably cause for you to enter but I'd
point out that none of the other nations
with our similar history England
Australia New Zealand none none of them
have this this was a constitutional
error by the Supreme Court that's
existed for a hundred years to the
denigration of all of our property
rights and that's why I've spent many
many years of my life trying to fix this
and that's why I think this legislation
is so
important thank you for your
testimony chair calls Chief Kevin
Walsh
good morning uh my name is uh Chief
Kevin Walsh I the police chief of the
town of Ryan New Hampshire I started my
career in law enforcement in New
Hampshire in 1987 and just to give a
brief outline the way New Hampshire does
it a lot of areas around the country are
going to start to follow which is all
the police officers get trained at the
same Academy that includes on search and
seizure so back in
1987 first day of class for search and
seizure a person's property per person's
home is there castle that's what all the
police officers in New Hampshire are
learning so when we see a sign for no
trespassing and there is not exent
circumstances that requires a search
warrant some of the things I listened to
in the testimony by the two gentlemen
are not accurate with New Hampshire law
enforcement that doesn't happen they're
talking about things that happen in
other states in other states and now
looking at New Hampshire law enforcement
in our Academy and how we're training
our officers and what we do I've been a
police chief uh since 2006 so right
around 16 years I've had some oversight
with different officers and different
circumstances and the circumstances that
these gentlemen are describing a search
warrant's already
required I I don't understand why this
bill is necessary our courts um as a
matter of fact do those rulings and take
care of people's property and their
persons specifically to make sure that
when law enforcement are doing these
searches are accurate if isn't exent
circumstances there isn't evidence of a
crime that isn't going to be destroyed
prior to getting a warrant the other
phrase I learned as a police officer in
1987 when in doubt get a
warrant and that's what the officers are
trained to do at One Police Academy it's
reinforced with policies and training uh
as you can see I am wearing a body War
camera our department just started that
we're about six to uh 7 months into the
program the body Waring camera is to be
worn we let people know that you're
being audio and videotaped if we're
going into private homes for a call for
service other than a domestic violence
or something that requires evidence
evidentiary value we turn it off at the
homeowners request we let them know that
it's on so a medical Aid call I would go
in I would let them know I'm wearing a
body War camera You' be an audio and
videotaped I would turn it off for their
privacy again person's home is their
Castle I have no business doing that
unless I'm doing something specific of a
law enforcement reason to have the
camera on police officers in New
Hampshire do respect people's property
and their
person trust is the most valuable thing
you can ever earn and law enforcement
realizes that we're on a trust Mission
we need to continue that bank account of
trust the gentleman to my right when
they're talking they're talking about
things in other states I'm confused it's
not happening here so why are we doing
this uh someone brought up
is there a single instance in New
Hampshire that you're talking about they
said
no I found that extremely compelling as
to why this bill shouldn't even move
forward anymore and as far as a town
assessor yes they do go on properties
and take a look at the curtilage uh
they're going to be looking for required
permission if there's a no trespass and
sign it is my understanding the town's
policy that hires a private company they
do not move forward till they get in
contact with the property owner if there
is no sign they'll take a look outside
the curtilage they will knock on the
door ring the doorbell to see if they
can permission to to look in these are
the practices and standards that we're
already
following so again I'm I have no idea
what these two gentlemen are talking
about I don't mean any disrespect to
them but that's not what's going on in
New
Hampshire thank you Chief if if that's
what's going on in the Hampshire what
would be the harm in passing this bill
if you're already doing it would it
would it impact you in a negative way or
law enforcement I think it would and
I'll give you a circumstance um I was a
young officer we were call for a 911
call for a domestic I go out there was
an apartment building for apartments not
a thing it's 1:00 in the morning we left
because there was no obvious signs and
it says no trespassing so we don't go up
on the porch and knock it on the doors
there was no other than the call we got
called back a second time so that draws
in the suspicion that something's going
on I have an officer dropped me off I
stood at the side of the house out on
the public way on the sidewalk and
waited for the for the third call or
what I heard was a domestic assault
going on or an assault inside the house
I knocked on the door person came out
closed the door no need to go in
everything's all set here officer I had
to call the other units down we had to
make our way in and it was in fact a
domestic assault that was
ongoing those trespassing signs are
going to be a hindrance and prevent us
from doing our quality of of life to
other people and and what I find most
disturbing about this is that there is
not a single incidence that's specific
to New Hampshire as to why we're putting
this in our system already
works I I don't understand why this
would even move forward and it is going
to be a hindrance to it because there's
other levels they're talking about
government there's the assessors that
evaluate property they're working for a
town they're working for the government
they're out doing their job to do the
assessing they do respect the signs um
you talk about uh hunting you know we
advise people B based on Hunting rules
and trespassing that they need to post
their land 300 ft apart with with the
signs if they do not wish to have people
hunting there uh drones that was
something that did come up I know
there's some cases as a law enforcement
officer if we're going to fly a drone
over somebody's personal private
property their
Castle we get a warrant because we have
time to get it if it's those
circumstances unless there ENT
circumstances we don't go on people's
property and we have to articulate that
specifically um representative
roads thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
I so on I'm looking at line 23 it says
upon entering private land a government
agent shall immediately notify the
landowner leas to your occupant if
notice can be reasonably made and it's
talking about if there's an extend
extenda
circumstance I I know I can't help it um
is that something that is already done
or how would this conflict where it says
shall if it can the officers are already
doing it at least from what I've
experienced in my 37 years as a police
officer however there are other
circumstances where this is just going
to contradict what we're actually doing
and again I'm going to remind the
committee you asked the most important
question
here is there a single instance of why
we need this bill I mean it's like we're
just making laws to make laws we already
have best practice standards we have
constitutional laws that are in place
and those best practice standards in
writing in training are being followed
based upon
that represent
new that am
Muse
represent
wheeler thank you for taking my question
Chief Walsh um you had mentioned that uh
the legislation would hinder your
ability to go into a domestic violence
case where there were four Apartments
but I'm looking at um line 20 here of
page one and it says to respond to
exigent circumstances such as a
lifethreatening emergency or another
immediate threat to Public Safety that
was either reported to the agent or the
agent personally observed would you then
say that you personally observed the
domestic violence case which is what you
said in your uh account and therefore
under this law would be allowed to enter
that case and deal with the domestic
violence case as you see fit under this
law I can see a defense attorney filing
a motion that what I was hearing was
inaccurate so therefore if fruits from
the poisonous tree again something I
learned the first day at the police
academy on the search and seizure if the
court would rule that what I was hearing
as being an assault was in accurate and
I was guessing this law would help the
uh defense to have anything we saw after
going to that door to be thrown out and
therefore none of the evidence of the
domestic assault would be able to be
entered into the court and again we're
letting a victim
down can I get a followup Mr chairman
yeah thank you appreciate that um
so I I will leave that for then and you
and I can discuss about that after I
don't want to debate you um but my
followup is you said that the police
standards and training already train the
officers to do a lot of what's
articulated in the bill um I think the
chairman already asked a similar
question
but if it's already articulated in the
bill in in police standards and training
what's in the bill is already uh in the
rules and they're already trained to do
that um none of us live forever none of
us work forever wouldn't you see it as a
good thing
based on the fact that uh skippa and his
great training you and your great work
for your department might not always be
there and there might be an officer
somewhere down the line who has less of
a level of respect for the private
property rights of our citizens here in
New Hampshire less of a respect for the
community as you do and and might end up
doing what's outlined here in this bill
can we rely on on the training standards
is what my question really is that's a
very good question
um since 1987 these standards and
practices have been in place and we've
improved on it based on what we've
learned from people and Court rulings
and after I'm
retired the same standards of best
practice are going to be in place and
when myself as a department head has an
officer that would not be following best
practice standards we have internal
mechanisms in place that we're following
to ensure either they can respond on to
the training and if they can't then we
thank them for working at that agency
and one of the things that I think
everybody's aware of we're pushing
forward for stra State accreditation my
agency is one of them we're looking
forward to being one of the first and
that is to answer your question we'll
have those best practice standards that
after we're all retired hopefully on a
beach
somewhere these standards will be
followed because they're in place thank
you
Stone thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question in your
experience have you found that uh search
and seizure training continues based on
different court cases that come down or
is the basic training you receive at the
Academy the only search and seizure
information that you you gain throughout
your career a good question it's based
upon everything that comes down from the
courts we adjust that training to meet
those standards so we know that courts
are ruling in a certain way we need to
adjust policy and training with that
followup so you're talking about in
service you have yearly or updated
trainings yes and follow question so if
this bill was to come law that would be
part of the new training it would have
to be yes thank
you see no further questions thank you
for representa go ahead thank you so
much and thank you for you said um
you're going for accreditation is that
through Kalia or another organization
State of New Hampshire uh State
accreditation standards okay thank you
so much thank you if you'd like to know
more I'm on the board
any further questions seeing none thank
you for your testimony thank you
everybody for taking my
time uh you representative papovich
Miller am I saying it
right thank you Mr chair I I'm my name
is Daniel popovic Mueller and yes due to
frequent practice you are doing great at
pronouncing the last name I'm going to
be very very brief and I I just want to
State really that relying on the
Constitutional protections is all nice
and good but they do leave a lot of gray
areas and a lot of reasonable people
disagree on what the interpretation of a
particular constitutional provision is
it is better to just have a clear law
that the legislature sets the standards
needed to get onto private land and I
I'm finding a bit conflicted when
hearing testimony that says really we
are already doing all this but then if
you pass this law we won't be able to do
some of the things we are doing you kind
of you can either have your cake or eat
it but you cannot have your cake and eat
it too either the legislation already
follows the standards and then there is
no harm in passing it or it requires
them to change what they're doing in
which case there is a clear need to pass
it so you know you got to just pick one
I appreciate the references to the
training and standards of the police and
I'm grateful that they are high they may
change over time I don't want to rely on
that when the legislature can set the
clear standards and plus officers do not
always act as trained we are humans we
make mistakes this is good legislation
that is needed to clearly spell out the
protections we have and I would
encourage the committee to support the
OTP motion and I'm done thank you thank
you for your testimony
thank um the chair calls John
garan Department
Labor good
morning my name is John garrian I am the
general counsel at the State Department
of Labor um I don't appear uh in support
or in opposition we are neutral on the
bill however um the Department's review
of this bill um has raised some concerns
for us as relates to our ability to uh
inforce and inspect and regulate uh
labor laws as uh here in the state of
New Hampshire um one of the ways that we
enforce labor laws is through
inspections of workplaces or of
elevators if you see a little
certificates in the elevator when you
come up and down uh or boilers in in
other instances um
that ability of the department and its
employees to do that has been codified
um in labor law in RSA 273 RSA 275 and
others um that authorities existed uh
fundamentally since
1911 um in order for us to protect the
workers and the public here in the state
of New Hampshire in the review of this
bill the language in it is very broad it
applies to all government AG not just
Law Enforcement Officers or um or
investigators um and so it it could be
that this bill would would styme or
limit uh the Department's ability to
enforce or to perform inspections of
workplaces private workplaces um or of
locations of say boilers or elevators in
order to um inspect them or to ascertain
uh if violations are occurring um one of
the the important parts of our ability
to inspect one is to see the workplace
as it is um and not in a state where an
employer has U been able to to amend or
to change um for instance perhaps their
youth labor law violations if there are
children working hazardous occa
occupations where they shouldn't be um
or other such things so the bill does
exempt um the fishing game officers uh
or fishing game Personnel in their
enforcement of Wildlife
regulations um our recommendation would
be to have the bill also exempt uh Labor
uh reg sorry labor inspectors uh or the
enforcement of Labor violations or just
regulatory um inspections for that
regard does your department um have any
cause ever to do inspections or
investigations on the property that's
related to single family
homes
I I don't like giving absolute answers
but no as close as you can get it's sure
um uh firing that's under construction
labor in the state has performed in a
variety of locations and situations I'll
say um so it's not outside their own
possibility but usually we're talking
about construction sites we're talking
about um commercial establishments but
uh it there are times where um that that
could come up depending on how the how
the employment situ situation works or
how the workplace works
okay representative Stone thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
when you show up to do a uh I guess a
spontaneous inspection do you announce
that you're there with the officials
that have control of the premise mying
is that's is that's is the practice yes
so you just don't Slither into someone's
uh place of employment and uh kind of
say hey I got
you uh we don't Slither okay thank you
to the best of your knowledge
representative
scitech do you inspect does the labor
department inspect home elevators
no that's an excellent question thank
you you know where I can get a home
elevator uh see no further questions
thank you for your
teson is there anyone else wish to
testify on this spill was not
testified before I close I would c a
question for the sponsor and um your um
person who helped you with this if you
could in the next 24
hours get us some New Hampshire cases
that have had to do with search and
seizure under the Open Fields Doctrine
we heard testimony that there's no cases
it's being done it's not being
challenged there's no problems if there
are we'd like to know and if not that's
important to know I hereby close the
public
heing
um 1276 it's 10:30 we're already late
with that I open a public hearing on
House Bill
1276 and invite the sponsor to introduce
the
bill actually I I I I'll explain why I
like it after I
know it's just extending you I don't
think it's okay that c just tra
thank
you yep
thanks this
committee uh you number of you probably
are looking at this going didn't we just
pass that last year and yes we did your
committee did pass it and we passed it
out of the house and over in the Senate
side they said we want to see it only
apply to people who are over 18 which
was missing from that and instead of
amending it they killed it and asked me
to put it in again with the language
saying over 18 so what you see before
you is the same bill we passed last year
but with the specificity of uh if you're
under 18 you still can't um own sell
possess blackjacks slungshot or brass
knuckles that's essentially it it
basically lines up with the way we sell
knives to of of large lengths can't buy
them switch blades and Long Knives if
you're under 18 so it just basically
lines up with that and and if there's
any questions I'll take
them I was going to start with the same
question from last year as what is a
slungshot but we'll just move on from
that um does this law if passed remove
any of the restrictions on felons
possessing weapons no does
it is the current state of law that I
can have all these things if I have a
hunting license yes but if I don't have
a hunting license I can't have them
correct thank you you can also have all
these things if you're law
enforcement
currently further questions seeing none
thank you anyone else wishing to testify
on this bill see none I hereby close
public hearing on House Bill
1276 we have a five actually we're g to
we're going to take 15 minutes before we
start the next
one what
say
e
I'm opening the public hearing for
Hospital
1276 no excuse me
1539 and I invite a spons chang the
Bill thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee
uh HB
1539 is relative to annulling
resentencing or discontinuing
prosecution of certain cannabis offenses
uh there is already a process for nment
right now in current law uh that process
is outlined
in RSA 651 colon DB um this bill amends
that section and then adds in some new
sections which open up the ability for
uh somebody and that's those new
sections are um let me see here uh after
651 inserting after section
b-5 the following new sections which are
651 Colon 5- c uh annulment of certain
arrests for and convictions of cannabis
um despite the fact that this
legislation is four pages long I would
like to think it is decently simple um
the process for annulments that I
brought forward here in this bill was
because of the fact that the legislature
seems to be moving rapidly towards
legalization of cannabis um the governor
has indicated support of legalization
the um Senate has moved more so than it
had in the past towards legalization and
it we have a bill that's coming before
the floor which I think is 17 to3 and
we'll be voting on that tomorrow so I
think it's it's clear especially given
the last few sessions the where we're at
with the legalization of marijuana
despite um some objections from some of
us here um there is an effort to move
forward to legalization and it looks
like decriminalization was the first
step to what the state will seemingly
inevitably do um given that uh and given
the fact that we've seen legalization
across the country and I'm a proponent
of legalization I support legalization
but I am concerned with what I'm seeing
in other places Colorado California
places that um don't have as robust an
analment process for their uh for people
who were convicted of of marijuana
charges and I'm concerned that the
situation that we're seeing right now
with the legalization of marijuana is
it's being legal legalized by the state
so people can sell buy or smoke it while
at the same time people who bought it or
sold it or smoked it are incarcerated as
a result of that and I think those two
realities oper ating alongside one
another is a is a a travesty of justice
and a bit of a moral quandry I suppose
that I think we should that we should
address and this is I think a process by
which we could address that
um I understand the cost for the
agencies in the legislation as written
would be High um or at least that the
cost would be there um it would require
new hearings it would require petitions
uh the legislation as it was written
requires the department to look
proactively at some of these cases um as
outlined based on the timeline
here um I would be open to amendments on
that on that on that end but I do think
that um the bill as it stands is sort of
the golden standard of where we should
be moving when it comes to the
annulments process and my direct resp
response to the fact that there is a
cost here would be that's the cost of
government that unfortunately sometimes
there there is a cost here um we
incarcerated these people uh for decades
based on this charge um and it's going
to take uh a cost when we remove that as
a crime in our books and need to anull
those people those people's records
that's that is um unfortunately you know
it it that is the the cost of government
and and that does take money and
resources but um that's that's the job
that we were elected to do um Mr
chairman I'll I'll I could go on for for
hours about this but I'll just end by
saying somebody's uh record does
seriously affect their ability to get a
job their ability to uh be a fully
functioning member of society without
illustrating everything that that
entails um and as I said in the
beginning it's a seriously unfortunate
situation where we have places all
across this country where it's legal to
buy sell and smoke um but people who
bought sold or smoked it are still um
convicted or have a charge on their
record which keeps them from getting a
job or keeps them from again being a
fully functioning member of society um I
mean that's just a really unfortunate
situation and I think on top of that if
we're going to do the state Monopoly
model it's an even more unfortunate
situation because the state that
incarcerated that person for again
buying selling or smoking is now buying
selling uh the product that it
incarcerated that person for so I think
just given where we're at here in New
Hampshire given where the movement
around cannabis is um and given how
important it is for somebody if the
crime is no longer there to have a clean
record um I introduced HP 1539 and I
really appreciate uh the that you have
given me here today Mr chairman thank
you um couple quick questions which
offenses specifically will it an
know it outlines on page one or the
first page of the text here and let me
find the line here um line 10 uh so this
is uh 651 colon
b-5 as amended here in the bill um line
10 section c uh cannabis related
offenses means the following any offense
under RSA
13-b so involving Canabis or per that
would go all the way up to trafficking
wouldn't it say that again would that go
all the way up to trafficking not on my
and no RSA 13-b involving cannabis or
paraphernalia intended for cannabis and
in terms of trafficking any other um any
other offense that doesn't have to do
with canvis and I appreciate you me the
time to to answer that no I mean
trafficking in cannabis um if someone
the selling of cannabis yeah if someone
was selling you know 50 lbs that would
be a trafficking I believe level offense
would this pardon trafficking
charges or not pardon excuse me a n well
that's um uh
the I think it would be have to be no
more than The Possession limit and I
think 50 lbs would be over The
Possession limit as as Illustrated right
now in current law and um so that's what
my question is is it yeah that's more
simple is would this only anull things
that we are about to possibly make legal
in other words selling a massive amount
of marijuana without um whatever
permission or whoever is going to be
able to sell it would still be a
crime so we wouldn't be pardoning uh
excuse me annulling things that would
still be a crime correct yes and it it
it does outline that it is The
Possession limit is the uh limit for um
annulment and and as I said in the
beginning of my uh testimony here the
process for Anan is already there this
makes it so the 34s of an ounce is
turned to The Possession limit so it it
will update itself based on whatever the
legislature decides with hb1 1633 and
the other bills that we have before us
so if the legislature decides to do
nothing then this text will sit there as
taking up space in the criminal code
book um saying The Possession limit and
The Possession limit will be the three4
of the ounce that that we have right now
gotcha representative rhs thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question representative wheeler I'm I'm
trying to read this very quickly and I
apologize if I missed it um so it sounds
to me that this is all on assumption
that this will become legal before the
current governor leaves office so is
this to say that if it does not become
legal then this is this whole bill is a
wash or is it your intention even if it
doesn't become legal that this still
goes into
effect I don't think that the bill would
be a wash if it doesn't become legal um
I I would say that even if 1633 doesn't
pass on the floor tomorrow that this
bill would still be a good thing based
on the fact that there are indications
politically and you know obviously we
can't um
there are serious indications that
legalization could pass this year or in
the next bium so I think this bill is
good but aside from whether or not
legalizations passes this bill is good
because having it be no more than The
Possession limit rather than 34s of an
ounce I think fits where we're at here
in New Hampshire Better given the fact
that the 34s of an ounce could change so
drastically or whether it goes down or
goes up you know if we make it a quarter
of an ounce then The Possession limit
based on this bill would be a quarter of
an ounce and you could only anull your
crime if it was a quarter of an ounce so
I I think it would be good to have even
if uh whatever legalization bill doesn't
pass in uh in this
bium representative sik thank you and
thank you for taking my question um so
just to make sure that I understand um
in this bill so if there are PE for the
people who are currently inar ated for
um marijuana specific related offenses
can you just clarify for me the process
by which they would be released I can um
let me find just I can give you the uh
the piece of the bill that does do that
here let me just find the exact page
um I believe it is on page
[Music]
three page four thank you
um page four line four thank you m Madam
Vice chair um the offense is not
eligible for resentencing under this
section uh well that's
resentencing okay well um I think it
might be
um I was seeing it on page three because
I I I believe that it has to do with the
resentencing um I'm I'm I because I I
think you were skipping to the to the
middle of it I think I was right when I
said it was page three um and the
resentencing piece comes in it starts
here on line 16 page three 651 colon 5-d
resentencing for cannabis offenses and
as outlined in the bill you know without
reading it directly here um essentially
if somebody is currently in prison they
can petition the court based on solely a
cannabis charge uh the court that they
were convicted on um to have that
sentence recent and and it starts here
on line 16 and that uh chapter goes
until uh line 37 on page
four in a second I just that I have a
question to clarify that so if a person
is arrested and sentenced to
jail and it was on a cannabis charge but
it was also a Firearms charge and maybe
a couple other things thrown in there
would that not require the court to have
a whole new sentencing hearing where
they decided what the sentence should be
based on the other
charges I believe Mr chairman that um it
would have to be solely a cannabis
offense so if somebody was arrested for
a Firearms charge as well then they
would not be eligible for annulments
under this bill um and that also
includes people who and I did that in my
notes for the initial testimony I forgot
to say that um that includes people who
took a plea deal so if you were going to
be convicted for something took a plea
deal and then it was just a cannabis
charge that would not count for an
helment it would have to be you were
convicted for solely a cannabis charge
and then or paraphernalia charge based
on cannabis and then you would be
eligible for analment but anyone who was
arrested and there's so so much text
here it's hard to while you're at the
dis find exactly what I'm looking at but
I know I can find afterwards because I
know it's here anyone who is arrested
for anything other than a marijuana
charge would not be eligible for this
representive s your
followup thank you and I apologize
because my brain is trying to make sense
of all of it um
so if someone were
serving three years for um a marijuana
specific charge without any other
charges they by by through this bill
they would appeal to a judge to be
resentenced is that what I'm
understanding yes and and with the hopes
that the judge would then release them
yes um well anyone who applies for
resentencing I suppose hopes that the
person that they get released but
um I'm trying to find the exact piece in
which it outlines what the court does
here so apologize um I believe that it
the answer to your question would be
found on page four line 26 which says
that the court may find that
resentencing is the interest is in the
interest of Justice uh but that a
complete reduction oh I'm sorry that's
not that isn't it but that is around the
same place where it essentially says
that the court has the discretion to
look at what the sentence would be and
if it's not in the it does outline uh in
this whole page four whether or not if
it is in the interest of Justice or not
um then that petition will be uh granted
thank you representative
Balden thanks for taking my question I
know that you um enjoy learning history
and I was wondering if you know of um
folks who received
any um annulments or pardons after the
end of alcohol prohibition I know that
FDR gave some but I don't know if maybe
there were some at State levels as
well oh it's a great question
representative Balden actually I don't I
don't know my prohibition history as
much as someone who who supports
prohibition should I suppose but I do
know that there were some annulments
given out I don't think that there was a
a federal bill passed in the
1930s that uh opened up the door for
annulments at large but I know that
there is a process by which someone
could anull I don't know when that uh
process came into effect though yeah
thank you
represent
Muse your
mic I did have a question about the uh
at the top at the top of your bill um it
says The Possession limit means
whichever of the following quantities is
greater uh 2 ounces of cannabis and 5
gram of hashes or an amount of cannabis
that's legal under the new hampsh Under
New Hampshire law for adults 21 and over
to possess
doesn't this bill basically Raise The
Possession limit by itself by making
that
change I mean I think that the without
giving you a direct answer because I I I
don't know that direct answer off the
top of my head I think you might be
right uh that might be an oversight that
needs to be
amended thank
you representative Stone thank you thank
you for taking my question do you have
any numbers for currently incarcerated
individuals who are either detained in
the New Hampshire state prison or in
County facilities for a sole possession
of marijuana I do have those numbers
somewhere on my phone but not off the
top of my head would you be able to
provide those to the committee I could
thank you is it is it more than 10 yes
that are currently serving just on
marijuana charges just on marijuana
charger that would be an olded under
this bill I believe so yeah based on my
conversations with the ACLU thank you um
representative here at
Gathering thank you for taking my
question um actually a representative
Stone question was the same as mine but
I just want to take it a little bit
further did you actually talk to anyone
in the
dolc about the conversation about the
bill or about how many people um they
have they believe would be effective by
the bill
no okay thank you representative new
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question um I wanted to highlight
we're talking about um representative
celik was talking about you know the
process of of review or or how that
would go about so on page three um line
TW lines 24 to 29 um no later than 90
days after the effective date of this
section the Department of Corrections
and the superintendent of each house of
correction shall conduct a search to
determine all uh individuals so that's
kind of that uh lays out the proc
process as far as I'm concerned um my
question was I did receive a call um
from someone who was uh concerned about
the idea of um a related charge that
wasn't necessarily for cannabis but it
was uh part of that process and I I
believe what he had said was that he uh
tried to flush it so it was um uh
interfering with evidence or or
something yeah there you go destruction
of evidence would um would this piece of
legislation address something like that
that charge
are you saying would that person be
eligible for an nment based on an
obstruction of justice charge yeah would
they would the obstruction of of Justice
would that be part of the I think
unfortunately that the circumstances in
that case would prevent him from from
being aned under this bill um because of
uh what he was charged with and I I just
don't know if there would be a way to
allow for an nments of obstruction of
justice without getting into much Haier
territory than we already are with um
the canvas charges gotcha thank you
appreciate
it representative Manion thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question right in the sun I know you've
been waiting for it so I just began
slithering through this bill so bear
with me
um there was a bet to get that word in
there so we're talking about from what I
looked like 34 of an ounce 2 ounces
small amounts uh for possession however
we're also talking about people
incarcerated for 3 years
are there a lot of people that are
incarcerated for State Prison sentences
that have small possession charges or
are we going back to the people who are
trafficking the five pounds the 50
pounds are those the people that are in
state prison and does this actually
apply to them now well this applies to
anyone who gets a charge so I don't
think that there would be any specific
uh application to uh state prisons I
mean if you have a if you have a charge
from anywhere if you happen to have been
in the state prison because of a c
Canabis charge then you would be able
and eligible for this bill if you're in
a state prison because of uh sale of 50
lbs of cannabis and somehow you had 50
pounds of cannabis and you weren't
selling anything else it was solely a
cannabis charge you're not eligible for
this uh bill because you were uh
trafficking in uh significantly high
quality of of cannabis and you were you
mean quantity not Quality quality
exactly and uh that would be that would
not be eligible for the bill um
yeah seeing no further from Mr PR Mr
told me he was gonna get me um
representative Murray would you like to
um provide some clarity to committee on
The Possession limits currently as we
discussed sure Mr chair um I was just
going to say I wonder if maybe the two
ounces came from the fact that two anas
is The Possession for if you have a
medical card currently um and then it's
I believe 3/4 if you don't have a
medical card um but well I hate to look
stupid on the dis but for representative
Murray I'd be happy to do that um I
guess that's what we're looking at here
representative Muse is the medical uh
limit there so I wouldn't support an
amendment for that then yeah well
actually so what you'd be right now it's
a uh violation if you have more than the
the 3/4 of no up to 3/4 of anounces of
ation above that I believe is a
crime so what this bill would do would
make it legal to have up to two ounces
that's a big jump from from a violation
at three
quarters do you see what I mean I I see
what you mean that's a if the two o if
the 2 ounces is Medical Only yeah we
could amend it to say that I mean if
that's if that yeah I think the
amendment would be that the the part
that isn't Criminal would be the part
that whatever is legal for for people
without a medical card leaving the
medical part out of this whole bill
basically yes because they're already
exempt yes correct okay
so all right representative
Stone after looking at your bill and
listening to your testimony and some of
the things have come up today uh I guess
this more kind of a statement but if
you're going to be doing any uh
amendments I'd be more inclined to
support misdemeanor level offenses
versus any felony drug trafficking
offenses such as you know intend to
distribute non-narcotics under
318b so if you're looking at crafting a
bill I would urge you to take a look at
your levels of offenses for analment
represent Stone um I had the same
concern but it maybe you'll find it in
the bill but I believe what he's
represented to us is that that wouldn't
qualify for the analment those level of
charges it only would qualify for
misdemeanor below yeah for people with
and i would support that yeah anything
just to clarify if I may Mr chairman
yeah sure um anything that is where the
possession limit is at so right now The
Possession limit is three4 of an ounce
if you have anything over that it
wouldn't apply so followup is how can
anybody in the state prison for those
amounts yeah that's well I'm interested
to see what numbers are too and he's
going to get those for us believe thank
you um I would encourage everybody to uh
to read this bill thoroughly between now
and Friday um because obviously none of
us have so um it is four pages long but
we need to dig into it further questions
for representative
Newman yeah I'm I'm I'm just curious as
on page uh two at the top of the page
where all of the all of
these um directions on what what shall
be an offense and related offense and
what they have to prove and go through
all of that um I'm I'm just wondering if
if that needs to be that detailed in the
bill or is there some way you could do
it
without quite all of that
information I'll talk to you offline
yeah if you could clarify that question
talk to you offline
um yeah although any simplifications
would be appreciated um see you no
further questions thank you thank you
what we
got chair calls Dr Hannah The Honorable
Dr
Hannon
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee uh my name is Joe Hannon
uh a little bit of quick background I
was on the uh first study commission to
study legalization and taxation of
marijuana and back in I think it was
2018 um and I was also involved in
writing legislation for the last several
helping with the legislation for the
last several years for
legalization um a lot of what I wanted
to say was already said which is great
because it'll cut my time down so that's
why I did a little longer introduction
sorry um you know jobs housing another
thing that was left out was student
loans people and I have a senior in high
school right now if someone is a
conviction they can't even get student
loans uh for felony convictions on their
record it's very difficult uh housing uh
all kinds of stuff so we hear about the
harms that drugs can cause and that's
why we have locked people up for so long
and that's our rationale but we never
look at the other side of it which is
how much harm we've caused because of
locking people up taking away their
opportunity to have a job to have a
college education to have a home these
are things that are even more important
and I I don't want to debate whether
it's uh worth putting someone in prison
or not releasing clearing their record
because you know they were under 3/4 of
an ounce or they had 3/4 plus 001 ounces
that would put them over the limit now
they have to live with this for the rest
of their lives I think it's silly that
we're going to potentially profit as a
state like we heard and that we're still
going to keep people held accountable
for things that now the state is
currently making money off of I think
it's egregious and it's and this bill
says I think the words are actually in
here
um you know the uh there should be a
presumption that the granting the
position would be in the interest of
Justice due to the decriminalization or
legalization of cannabis for adults and
the unequal enforcement of cannabis laws
that that sounds uh uh we've heard
people ask we've heard people ask uh how
many people are still in jail for these
offenses we have to look at the
percentage of people U of either
minorities people of color who have been
incarcerated disproportionately the
numbers of people that actually use most
drugs and alcohol is pretty much the
same um you know you might have differ
slight differences in specifics about
what drugs are used and when but really
uh the the use the the rates for
addiction are not that different across
racial and uh economic uh lines so
because it's been disproportionately
enforced even in New Hampshire I believe
the numbers were I think one out of four
times more likely or four or five times
more likely to be incarcerated um I
think it's an egregious um wrong that
needs to be writed and also our own
state constitution says the crime must
fit the punishment so someone who has
34s of an ounce should be able to get
their records an olded I definitely
agree with that but should someone with
three quarters and plus 0.001 because
that's all you need to do to go over the
limit in something the difference
between a drug dealer and someone who
just has it for possession for cocaine
fentanyl is one gram if you're 1.001
over you're now a dealer whether it was
yours or not there's no you know they
didn't have to photograph you selling it
to a child necessarily to convince
people that you were dealing it's the
number
and I think that's uh it's a very
arbitrary and I think ultimately
capricious act that uh we've had in our
laws for a long time that I need I think
absolutely must be overcome and also uh
the fact that it was this bill it might
have a higher limit for The Possession
it's not changing the possession limit
necessarily it's changing the it's
allowing people to have their records
aned for that limit so someone who may
have had an ounce and got arrested years
ago now they may be a medical card
patient and they now can have 2 ounces
but that person wouldn't be eligible
unless we can raise that number to what
they can currently hold so uh we don't
do this for alcohol there's no
possession limits for alcohol I it's a
totally different discussion but I think
if we're going to put numbers on it we
should put the most uh you know uh
accommodating number we can to help the
most number of people to pursue jobs
pursue Advanced uh education and um to
change their lives and write some of the
wrongs that have happened due to our
past laws I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you
um
I would say baby steps um but you make
sense my question though is regarding
well I would suggest that if if we pass
this with the small limits and then we
passed that then it's a different
argument right now it's still illegal so
um regarding
Firearms
annulments are are not the same as a
pardon in my understanding right so
someone will still have a Nicks record
and still be prohibited even if we anull
their records is that that your
understanding
um I'm not really sure I'm not an
attorney so I don't want to testify on
the record for that um I wish you would
tell that to representative whole but go
ahead okay yeah
I um sorry yeah
um I I it does say that uh they don't
have to anull you know for reasons of
Justice you know um in the interest
annulments will not be in the interest
of justice so that can be proven it
doesn't even matter what the charge is
uh they asked about selling specifically
this bill does not allow for annulment
in the instances where someone was
selling to a to a minor or to a child uh
that is in the bill I believe it's on
page two uh line 30 an adult
Distributing cannabis to a minor or
using a minor to sell cannabis or uh for
for negligently storing marijana infused
products causing a minor to access them
so even if your kid got into your supply
or got into your medicine that would be
something that would not not be allowed
to be aned under this bill and anytime
not just selling it but having
convincing another child to minor to
sell it would also be not an nullable uh
behavior and um I think this is a good
bill for adults it still protects
children to a very strong degree and as
far as secondary crimes if someone uh
has if someone never had um a if someone
got possession and say when they were 18
years old and they got arrested for that
um it's a felony conviction it's on the
Nicks system they can't have a fire
I I I'm curious to know what that would
mean like you like you were asking what
it will mean uh federally but if
something's an olded it's you'd think
that it would never have happened but I
don't know if that's the case for Nicks
and also even if it was how do you get
off the Nick system which is a totally
separate debate technically I would
believe that the agency that submitted
the record would have to withdraw the
record but annulment doesn't isn't the
same as a pardon it only makes it public
facing I believe that it doesn't exist
so for your points with regard to um
housing Etc but I believe for law
enforcement the record's still there and
it still exists but I I could be wrong
myself that's why I was curious to know
if you um put on your Firearms hat if if
that was the case well if you became
Governor you could pardon everybody I
could but I won't be doing that so um
worth a shot yeah represent Manion thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question yes I'm still confused because
I'm hearing conflicting conflicting
testimony you you mentioned felony level
conviction so would this also apply to
not only the person who had a misam
possession charge but also a felony
dealing charge as well uh it would have
to be under the limit um
because
so drug dealing does not necessarily
mean someone was a drug dealer it's you
it's often times B I mean if someone has
a film of you if they if they record you
and you can ask the police the if anyone
officers are going to testify they'll
probably know even better than I am but
if someone is uh in the act of you know
caught in the act of selling they can
say someone's been been dealing but it's
often based on the amount if you look at
the the the rsas for the for the
penalties intent to distribute the
intent to distribute right so intent to
distribute would be something um purely
based on weight or amount um if you're
raising The Possession limits then you
would have to change that even for for
felony offenses if it's a small amount
now this would not cover someone who had
50 pounds or even a a pound that would
be out of the purview of this unless for
some reason they changed the possession
limits to be equal U to be the same as
the alcohol laws which we have which you
can get a whole truckload of Hennessy
and drive it wherever you
want I think thef would disagree with
that um I do want follow up on that so
you were talking about three qus 225
right they would be considered felony
intend to distribute possibly I I have
to check all right so my question would
be is where do we draw the line there so
how do we know the person in jail for
intent
was dealing 50 pounds
or you know 1 ounce we wouldn't know
that so they would all be eligible for
annulments according to this bill uh I
guess it would I imagine it would depend
on what they were convicted of if they
were convicted of a certain amount they
that would be in the court record I mean
they would have to have the number if
they don't have an amount to even put in
the record then they don't have enough
evidence to commit to to prosecute
someone I would guess so all guess I'm
not like I said I think we need to read
through the bill real closely because
yeah my understanding BAS the testimony
is that there would be a court hearing
where they would have to introduce
evidence and part of that would have to
say well look I only had this much
versus someone trying to say well it's
something and I think it it's tied to
the amount that we legalize so if unless
we legalize that amount so that's why
I'm curious about the felony people
incarcerated how can that be if this
would only apply to people that have a
certain amount so we're going to have to
sort
that on page three line four all
convictions and arrests for misdemeanor
or violation level offenses for
possession of cannabis shall be
automatically an olded within 6 months
the effectivity of the section of
Department of Safety shall remove any
such qualified convictions from its
records and notify the court from which
the case originated which shall place an
order of analment in the court file and
thereafter process the file in the same
manner as any other anold case so for
just the violations of misdemeanors it's
automatic they they have to do it now
you can petition the you can go to the
court and say or the department of
safety and say hey check my record is it
clear if not you can still petition to
go to court and have it fixed this is
for any violations or not violations
sorry bad word for crimes beyond the
misdemeanor and violation level that
would have to be uh heard in court and
potentially for
resentencing thank you does that help
representative
scitec and further questions seeing none
thank you for your contribution this
morning um anyone else wishing to
testify in this bill who has not done so
seeing none I hearby close public
hearing
and 12:00 15 minute
break
hey I'm opening a public hearing on hb1
1270 and invite the sponsor to induce
the
Bill thank you chairman Roy and
committee members for the record I am
representative Joe Shapiro from Keen
chesher
16 um thank you for allowing me to bring
House Bill 1270 involving a small but
extremely important fix for our County
jails that this bill will provide I am
doing this on behalf of superintendent
Doug yzw of the cheser county department
of corrections as well as the other
County jails around the
state um prior to giving giving you the
specifics of this bill let me just say
that my request today involves no
judgment whatsoever on the corrections
practices at the chesa county jail
having practiced as a social worker in
that Community for um decades I've had
many opportunities to interact with
staff and incarcerated people at the
jail and um while the jail is far from
the best place to provide services for
mental health and substance misuse
issues I can attest to the the fact that
going way back in time our County County
Jail has been a leader in attending to
the mental health and substance misuse
issues that are so prevalent among those
incarcerated there
um the issue addressed in House Bill
1270 is a requirement that has been in
statue at least since the late 1980s and
I want to refer you to um chapter RSA
chapter 172b that I gave out and um
Point your attention specifically to
Roman numeral
3 it says that intoxicated or
incapacitated individuals were brought
to the jail for a maximum 24-hour stay
for protective custody so these are
people who are picked up someplace by
law enforcement um they haven't
committed a crime but they are um so
intoxicated that they are unable to um
be safe or maybe might create a safety
concern for somebody else that the
current practice is that they are um
they can be taken to a county jail and
the county jail has to um admit them for
a maximum of 24
hours so if you look at this RSA you
will see that
um the
jail is um immed immediately upon
lodging said person in protective
custody
um the Corrections Officers must contact
an alcohol counselor a clinical staff
person An approved alcohol treatment
person a nurse etc etc basically it says
that anybody who is admitted for
protective custody must have an
immediate assessment in terms of their
medical and um substance misuse needs
so this is far beyond what is required
for somebody who is brought to the jail
by law enforcement because they are
charged with a crime um and many of the
jails um um superintendent y yawe just
told me that um more than half of the
jails do not have um nursing or other
medical staff or substance misuse
professionals um that are on staff 247
seven so essentially this has been a
requirement that has not been complied
with for decades which
[Music]
um is not really fair to the
incarcerated people um but it is also
creates uh tremendous liability for the
counties and the um and the corrections
departments within the
counties
it also it also is not it it it's not
parody with people who are arrested for
a crime so really the the um focus of
this um bill is to remove that
requirement while we do not want the
County Corrections departments to be
saddled with an impossible to comply
with requirement we want to make sure
that this change in no way compromises
the safety of those who are housed for
protective custody therefore we have
added a stipulation that if in the
Judgment of law enforcement or the
corrections admitting staff there's a
potential
life-threatening um emergency then there
will be a request that the delivering
police agency have the incapacitated or
impaired person cleared by a hospital
emergency room this is not my area of
expertise but I am told that um
cooperatively these decisions are made
all the time only in the case when
there's a life-threatening emergency and
this is standard practice I mean there
might be people who testify who say
that's the case and there might be
people who testify say that's not the
case but that is my understanding
um our our ini our initial initial um
idea was to have everyone who was coming
for protective custody be cleared by an
emergency room and
um in retrospect that was not a good
idea I mean the emergency rooms are
already um overwhelmed um these people
would be more prone to being
uncooperative than other people um and
not everyone who is drunk or
incapacitated by um drugs is really
having a life-threatening
emergency so thank you for giving
consideration to House Bill 1270 while
I'm not wed to all of the specific
language um and there's some additional
language that kind of um codifies The
process by which law enforcement ends up
bringing someone to the jail like that
they might um check with family first or
um see if there's a friend who can take
um that P responsibility for that person
um if any of the other language um that
we've um tweaked is um a problem I hope
that once this committee has the bill
that they will focus on Roman num 3 of
section
172b colon 3 which is um a
longstanding problem for um for our
Corrections agencies to not be complying
with our own
laws thank you and I'm willing to take
questions although I know superintendent
Yaz from the chesher Department of
Corrections is here and he might be able
to answer answer technical questions
better than I thank you um in reading
the
statute I I maybe have a different take
on it um your law or proposed law um
deals more with you know covering
whether it there's a medical emergency
or a problem with the person my reading
of the current statute is it's it was
more of a um a a civil rights issue
where the person would have to be in
other words so that the police couldn't
just say I'm taking you for protective
custody cuz I think you're intoxicated
and the person would be sober and say
wait a minute you're just doing this to
harass me this says here because it says
they will determine whether said person
is indeed capacitated so in other words
it looked like a check on whether or not
someone needed protective custody versus
whether or not they needed medical help
um
so I guess my question is is if we
remove that language is there any check
on ensuring that someone put into
protective custody because they're
intoxicated actually needs the
protective custody versus just someone
doing that to them um and I have to read
the protective custody Statute in full
but it seems to me other states um offer
breathalyzer or something of that nature
to proove intoxication but I think we
can discuss that with law enforcement um
do you have any thoughts on
that that is very good
question Mike that is a very good
question and I've never thought about it
from that angle and that in part is
because it was brought to me yeah um
with a with a different interpretation
um and so I would have to really think
about that and look at that more myself
we certainly wouldn't want
people you know to be um sent to the
county jail as some kind of punishment
because they weren't getting along with
a particular police officer
right thank you um questions represent
Newman yeah just a question about I used
saying that intoxicated or incapacitated
is removed by the bill and I'm not sure
that I see that no I think that the the
um having a medical professional
determine that is what's removed isn't
it it's still in there but it has thank
you
yeah Sheriff call uh the chair calls
Sheriff Bill
Wright
good afternoon chairman Roy and the
members of this committee I'm belnap
County Sheriff Bill Wright I am
currently the secretary of the New
Hampshire Sheriff's Association I'm
representing uh the sheriff's
Association
today I'm testifying in opposition to
houseal Bill 1270 as it's written
relative to protective custody
statue a few things that I look at in
that we looked at with uh House Bill
1270 as introduced it draws some
questions as it relates to local jails
being removed uh from the first
section in talking about allowing County
correctional facilities as to lodging so
places like nashor and Manchester where
they actually have holding cells that
they could um be considered jails uh
that that part would be removed which we
don't think is
appropriate the bill is absent
definitions of what potentially
life-threatening medical emergencies
means is that the amount of BAC is it
the intoxication of drugs or a specific
kind of drug is it high blood pressure
abscess tooth skin infections these are
all things that we uh when we bring
people into the jail we get turned away
for and asked to get medically cleared
for
incarceration so during a protective
custody hold which is no more than 24
hours in in typically uh no less than 4
hours uh this would not be a good use
alarm enforcement to be doing medically
cleared for every incident that may uh
arise high blood pressure I bet if you
check my blood pressure now it's
probably up so you know again I don't
need to be cleared for you know
medically cleared for that uh there's a
removal of section five which allows the
refusal of the jail and Correctional
Facilities to accept intoxicated and
incap capacitated uh persons right now
when we make the request as a law
enforcement official to hold this person
for uh that
intoxication or
incapacitation traditionally that's
their they're accepted um this would
remove that that right that they it
could be arbitrarily
refused Section 8 was removed which
dissolves any type of uh immunity if you
will as it relates to this this
particular bill uh and it takes it out
of the uh basically it puts the civil
and criminal liability uh in the hands
of the uh the jail and the officers so I
don't know why that that would be
removed another thing that we looked at
was the usage of emergency department so
the Ed or ERS uh officers and deputies
when they're turned away at the jail or
Correctional Facility uh to get somebody
cleared medically cleared for
incarceration again some of that could
be a preist pre-existing issue uh
different infections and things
that they have on their skin we end up
spending uh a lot of time up the
hospitals trying to deal with um getting
them medically cleared now remember if
it's a skin infection or some uh form of
uh issue that's medical uh like a
abscess tooth or something we could be
we we get put at the end of the the list
as real emergencies come into the
emergency department so that's a concern
for
us not to mention that we have
departments across the state that are
rural when they travel 20 30 minutes to
the local jail or in cases like plumouth
um where they actually have to drive to
Graf County which is well over an hour
when they arrive at the jail uh for this
um
INX they get turned away and told hey
you need to go and uh get medical
clearance Our concern is that it's a
security risk to continue to have these
people out and about it's a it's a risk
to the public it's a risk to the uh
emergency staff as as well as law
enforcement we also take into
consideration how much time our law
enforcement is actually off the streets
dealing with uh some of these issues we
have local jails that are designed to to
hold people custody and control um your
local law enforcement officer out on the
streets that's that's not really their
function uh to to maintain these people
in custody and control for lengths of
time the PDS are not designed for that
nor nor are the police cruisers so on
and so forth I did want to read uh the
definition under
chapter 172
B1
specifically intoxicated means a
condition in which the mental or
physical functioning of an individual is
substantially impaired as a result of
the presence of alcohol in their
system incapacitated means that a person
as a result of his use of alcohol is in
a state of intoxication or mental
confusion resulting from withdrawal such
that he appears to need medical care or
supervision by approved alcohol
treatment personnel as defined in this
section to assure his safety or he
appears to present a direct active or
passive threat to the safety of
others now we have a lot of public
events that happen um across the state
different venues uh where alcohol is
either served or consumed sometimes in
large quantities and and law enforcement
is forced to uh deal with some of these
people uh we have learned that uh you
cannot reason with somebody who's in
intoxicated or incapacitated uh so we
try to do everything that we can in our
powers to find them a suitable person to
take custody of them uh normally it's an
adult over the age of 21 um when that
when we're not able to do that or able
to find somebody in a short period of
time again we're not going to wait for
somebody to come from Massachusetts to
go to Plymouth State University to pick
these people up so we bring them to our
local jails for that that
duration we need to we need to be able
to do that and we need not to be uh tied
up with bringing these people to the
hospital to check what their bac's are
and all that it can be easily done at
the uh at the
jail that'll conclude that I'll take
questions what is the um I mean is there
is there a cost to the county for these
medical exam I mean if these folks don't
have medical insurance who who pays the
bill when you bring them in there to for
all these
clearances I can't say that we've ever
received a bill at the county level so I
can I can only say that either they do
private insurance if they have it or
through Medicare Medicaid whatever they
normally have okay because we've heard
from other sheriffs that have had people
that not PCS but people that are
incarcerated for you know a year or more
and they're responsible for their
medical bills while they're in there so
I wondered if that applied here as well
I don't believe so because these people
are not technically committed
okay so there there's no court order
ordering these people and by definition
it's not uh intoxication uh PC is not so
protective custody is not considered an
arrest as it relates to criminal charges
and things so I don't believe that the
county would be on the hook for that so
the person then would be on the hook for
The Med emergency room visit um that you
guys brought him to for whatever test
they decide to do they would end up
getting a bill for that yes
um can you speak to what the chesher
county uh Sheriff I assume that you
folks talk that they seem to be having
an issue that they asked for this
bill so I I have not personally spoken
to the chesar sheriff about this okay I
just thought as the the sheriff's
Association might you might know the
majority of the sheriff's Association
are the ones that that discussed it and
determined that this would be
appropriate thank you um representative
n thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I'm wondering you
know I'm sure that there are some
differences between um counties and and
facilities in different areas and I'm
wondering if
um is it that that um that the facility
that you run has the capacity to be able
to do this and maybe it's not um that's
not a possibility uh in in all
cases well I can't speak for what they
have for housing at different counties
uh I know that when we're bringing
people to a jail a County Jail
um if that jail was full let's just say
uh that the superintendent has the
ability to uh ask for the person to be
transported to another jail facility so
we do this and and we do this here in uh
belnap County because of bike week so
motorcycle week uh we basically emptied
our jail and and um you know have it
available for what for our event that's
going on can I follow up real quick so
um the I mean specifically what I think
um is trying to be addressed here is
medical clearance right right um and so
I'm wondering if uh you know it it would
seem that that would in order to be able
to have that in your facility in each
facility which is something that you
would think is a a time sensitive thing
right you want to make sure that
somebody is okay to be um you know um in
custody right um is there the capacity
across the board in in all of these
facilities where there is someone who is
available at all times to be able to do
that a medical professional to be able
to do the assessment I don't know what
other jails have for uh medical staff or
what their capabilities or competency is
I I cannot legitimately answer that okay
thank
you Sheriff if you would for the benefit
of the of the committee take us through
a a typical PC from your end so what
you're notified by a law enforcement
department hey we're coming in with one
protective custody what happens Well
normally it starts um I'll I'll use uh
the loud and racetrack because we work
down there on occasion and um you know
we'll will end up getting either a call
to identify somebody who's being
disruptive um once we make that
identification of them we talk to them
and we determine whether or not they're
intoxicated or impaired to some degree
uh most of the time they're they're
impaired to the point of intoxication or
incapacitation and at that point uh we
try to get them somebody to take custody
of them at that point and get them back
to where they need to go when that fails
we end up having to take them into
physical custody and then we transport
that person to the local jail and fill
out the detainer request for a hold for
you know for
INXS while at the jail they
traditionally will do a a breath test a
preliminary breath test and it'll come
up with some form of result to show that
they're not having a medical issue as it
relates to like diabetes or something
that presents like an intoxication or
incapacitation as long as that shows
that they're uh you know over uh the
normal 08 legal DWI intoxication
impaired um BAC they'll accept them in
and um and and then normally that's they
get held for four hours or more
depending on their intoxication level uh
nothing prohibits the jail from
continuing to make phone calls or allow
uh the person to be released again we've
had times where we've had people that
were completely in inated and that um
you know we brought them to the jail and
they called somebody from another state
like Massachusetts and the family member
came up and and uh took custody of them
so that's that's been a pro the normal
process is what about medical screening
so the jail does their own medical
screening uh those of us who work in the
streets we don't traditionally do any
form of medical screening unless there's
obvious illness or injuries uh something
that needs either uh immediate attention
you know on occasion we do take people
into custody that are intoxicated they
they don't want to go to the jail uh
they start hitting their head off the
cage of our car and end up splitting
their uh you know end up splitting their
their forehead open uh and then we need
to divert to the to the uh ER in order
for them to get uh bandaged up so that
does happen on
occasion thank
you representative Stone thank you and
thank you sherff for taking my question
you mentioned uh you cover Lowden and
you also have Bike Week how problematic
would this bill be for your department
operationally if it was to go forward
with your course of doing business
during those high volume times well I
think it would be um very problematic it
would take deputies off the off the
deputies and officers off the road for
extended periods of time uh to get uh
Hospital clearance uh for people who are
in toxicated or incapacitated uh to some
degree that ultimately um when we get to
the hospital we utilize these resources
and we get told the same thing uh every
time that there's nothing really you can
do you got to let them Silber up it's
all about uh monitoring the person and
making Ure that um you know they're not
vomiting vomiting and and aspirating on
it or uh you know that that they're
being monitored so and that's what again
jails are designed to be a constant
monitoring and they they have a lodging
they're a lodging facility
followup in the course of a motorcycle
week what's the volume that you're
familiar with being taken to the jail in
regards to either protective custody or
intoxicated individuals well I've been
at the sheriff's office at Bel County
now for uh just over 18 years and uh and
I can tell you at one point uh we had
150 people that cycled through the jail
within a week and other times we've had
20 it it all depends on the event and
the weather and all that uh now I
mentioned uh bike week and I mentioned
NASCAR I I know that uh we have a
captain here from Guilford that will
probably testify to mebrook uh which
brings you know can bring in a
significant amount of people um we do
PSU for their spring flings and things
uh we've been out to uh we had Pumpkin
Fest out in uh Keen that we participated
in so we we've traveled all around to
help support local La enforcement and uh
so we're not just centralized to one
specific area or one specific event uh
but again these uh we do encounter uh
people when they're in these Mass um
groups and they're you know they there
to have a good time and sometimes uh uh
as they continue to indulge in in uh
alcohol they their ability to make good
choices sometimes goes bad and uh we
take them into custody again for Public
Safety and and to make sure that there's
no disruptions thank you um Sheriff
isn't it isn't it in a way um better
for an intoxicated person I mean in a
lot of these cases couldn't you also
charge them with disorderly conduct and
instead of doing that you you you kind
of cut him a break and put them in
protective custody so if this were to
pass you may end up having to charge
more people with disorderly just to not
have to deal with all that is that true
or no yes that's true we we could charge
people with disorderly conduct we could
uh charge them with inciting Riot we
could there's other charges that we
could most certainly uh go with
sometimes we have uh people who are not
so cooperative and being taken into
custody that we could probably charge
with resisting arrest but we really try
to reserve those for for people who uh
really need to be charged with that and
and to to be heard on that so uh we try
not to do uh extreme indifference with
these people we we try to first thing
that we do is we try to get them a a a
sober person to come take custody of
them we most certainly don't want to go
through the paperwork of dealing with
the you know at the jail we don't want
to go through medical uh clearance we we
would prefer to to release them to a
sober uh reasonable responsible adult
and uh and have them go sleep it off
wherever they're going to end up where
it comes into a problem is when they uh
when they have a you know again this
bill talks about releasing them to a
reasonable person well what is the
definition of a reasonable person is it
the 18-year-old uh child that is
required to pick the the parent up
because they know what's going to happen
if they don't and uh when they get home
is there going to be additional uh
problems and and normally the officer
who takes these people into custody when
we get to the jail uh we normally tell
the the uh the people at the jail the
Corrections Officers that this person
really needs to be held for a period of
time and some of that's as a coof period
too depending on the event that that may
have got us to to draw our attention
there uh again we don't just uh just
come into contact with people when it
comes to intoxication normally it's
because we've been called there for some
form of a problem or we've identify that
there's something going
on in your opinion if this were to pass
though could it result in more people
being charged with disorderly and things
of that nature instead of just getting
the the the PC it very well could be
thank you and and the prerogatives could
end up turning into well if we're going
to get stuck at the hospital for four
hours then it's going to be making it
worth its while and people could end up
getting charged uh accordingly I'm not
saying it's right but it very well could
be um it could
happen um representative
Murray thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I might just be a
little confused but from my
understanding I thought that it's
already a requirement that the person
like the individual being taken into
protective custody is evaluated and
that's like the issue that's trying to
be addressed because there isn't um
capacity for that evaluation to happen
in these um County jails not all of them
I guess um I don't know I'm just
confused about like is this actually
requiring uh additional work or is it
just providing other Pathways Beyond a
um uh that taking place in the jail you
know within that 24 hours so the jail is
supposed to be doing these evaluations
within within the walls of the jail so
the Corrections Officers the the people
who are housed in that that that
location that facility are the ones that
are supposed to be causing that to
happen the law enforcement officers that
are out on the street that are policing
the streets right now are the ones that
were this bill as introduced will cause
them local police officers to
potentially end up spending more time uh
at in a hospital setting with these
people who are were intoxicated or
incapacitated just to get them into the
jail to be held so the question would be
is even if they were being evaluated who
do you want to do the evaluation the
people that are uh that are in the
position to do custody and control
because that's their primary job or the
officers that are the law enforcement
officers that are on the street that are
supposed to be out there enforcing the
laws um okay that that helps me
understand it a little bit better I
guess my um concern would be it feels
like something needs to change though
because the jails are saying that they
don't have or not all of them have the
capacity to do those evaluations within
24 hours in the in the jail cell once
someone's held so I guess is your main
concern kind of like the transfer
responsibility being to the officers and
that it should still be housed within
the jail system somehow even if the
process changes a little yes so I
believe that there's a separation
between the corrections personnel and
the law enforcement Personnel on the
streets and unfortunately it feels like
based on this bill that the uh that it
would be pushed on to the law
enforcement officers who should be out
on the street
dealing with the crimes that are
occurring is it true that in in some
jurisdictions there may only be one
officer on during a given
shift yes and in in a lot of cases now
especially in uh like I can speak
specifically for belnap County we have a
lot of departments that have now gone to
on call status so they're not even
readily available uh when you call them
so if that one person is tied up with
the medical nobody's covering the town
now
yes thank you further
questions representative
Newman could you just comment further on
your objection to the local jail being
taken out I mean I I'm just yes so
there's a section that's currently in in
the legislation that talks about um that
uh lodged the person and what struck
struck out is in a local jail or County
Correction Facility which is a key
component to to section c in that
uh now it speaks to local jail later on
in the in the um the bill but with that
strikeout it it makes it sound like that
that we're going to actually the way
that reads is um Lodge the person for
said person's protection for up to 24
hours in the County Correctional
Facility or until the keeper of said
facility judges the person no longer be
intoxicated and then it goes on from
there um but I I want to make sure that
the the uh police departments that have
the ability to provide their own jail
and I list and I know that nashwa in
Manchester have their own holding
facility they have their own booking
officers people who are actually
assigned to that location that can hous
these people for that short duration of
time uh so under 24 hours before they
get
released thank you for that
answer follow up
uh and there's one place where where
jail is not lined out so but but those
places have the capacity to keep people
for 254 hours is that correct okay yes
yeah thank
you see no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank
you and chair calls
um Doug Doug
iosu
YZ
good afternoon and thank you Mr chairman
and committee members uh for hearing
this testimony my name's Doug Yaz I'm
the superintendent at Chester County
Department of Corrections representing
the County Corrections superintendent
affiliate we are in support of House
Bill
1270 in fact we
are the group that initiated the process
of seeking
changes um over a year ago we identified
an issue of significant concern with the
language representative Shiro spoke to
this uh primary
concern I'll address that in more detail
momentarily but the real concern is that
the current language in the statute
requires us to provide a response and
services for persons held for protective
custody that are largely unavailable
within the current resources of our
jails as well as the local
communities given this we propose as a
priority change within the amended Bill
the elimination of language in B colon 3
Roman numeral 2 through 4 that most
notably includes the requirements that
jails immediately upon lodging the
individual contact a designated alcohol
counselor clinical staff person of an
approved alcohol treatment program with
detoxification capabilities or a
professional medical staff person at a
licensed General Hospital emergency room
for
screening well these resources don't
exist uh none of them not even nursing
exists in six out of the 10 jails on a
247 basis that language implies bringing
someone out to see a a counselor
clinicians in mental health or substance
abuse counselors are not staffed 247 in
our jails nor were they ever that I know
of and at the time of the the language
in this
statute uh that is our primary concern
um the
um seeking the resources outside should
we try to do it is neither practical nor
affordable especially given that the law
as you've heard allows us to hold the
person for only up to 24 hours and often
that period of detainment as you have
heard is significantly less just as the
officer on the street has has an
opportunity to find a responsible adult
to take care of that person we have that
opportunity beginning as soon as we do
take custody and sometimes we'll release
a person within a matter of a few hours
to a responsible adult so the idea of
bringing them out to the community to
get those
resources given this is a protective
custody hold especially and the time
frames involved May makes no sense to
us now
additionally
um under Section uh Roman numeral 1 C
the the proposed amended language now
States if in the Judgment of the peace
officer or the County correctional
superintendent or their design the
person is experiencing a potentially
life-threatening medical
emergency they may require the police
agency to have the person cleared by the
emergency room of a licensed General
Hospital prior to receiving the said
person it still does include the
requirement after medical clearance that
we shall not refuse to admit the
person now I'm going to say we are not
trying to use the emergency room to
replace our lack of resources this was
really um a minor change
to something that's really um to make
something more explicit that's already
happening uh rarely but
occasionally both with protective
custody holds or charges it really does
not matter we often make a collective
decision with our law enforcement police
Partners about seeking Medical Care our
recent data from 2023 among all jail
uh we we pulled the data about 1 half of
1% of the time are we quote refusing or
by agreement in many cases redirecting
that person to get medical
attention as to the definition of
lifethreatening and and the the debate
about that um that is a judgment call
being made by law enforcement because
most of the time
neither the officer on the street or in
the jail is going to have anyone
medically trained to help make that
call although we've added that language
into this proposed bill it is really not
changing anything that's been happening
and I can't speak with certainty to
every County but for the majority of
counties I think we partner together and
make that decision responsibly and often
we agree as to when a person needs to go
up for for medical
clearance the last change that's in here
um and I again emphasize it's really a
standardization of existing policies and
practices there's some minor language
change and that amended language now
does State quote where possible contact
a family member or responsible adult and
release the person to this individual
who's willing to assume responsibility
for the intoxicated or incap
incapacitated person the changes to this
subsection are again relatively minor
simply suggesting where possible the
police make an attempt to call or
otherwise contact a responsible third
party before resorting to option
C that would be transporting the person
to the jail as you heard the sheriff say
that often happens
anyway uh it doesn't always happen it's
at the discretion of the
officer nothing ultimately in the
language of this bill removes that
discretion or compels any different
action or behavior on the part of the
police before bringing a person to us
there was some concern among the
municipal Association that it wouldn't
interfere with their
discretion would create more time making
an assessment about a probability of
harm and that could increase expenses
again if you look at the language it's
not compelled in any any way shape or
form um in summary our primary concern
was to remove that language that
promises or requires care and services
that cannot be provided uh in our jails
right now
um I would say this that if the
committee were to see the the other uh
language as a significant obstacle we
would be willing to forgo those changes
as long as um RSA 17 2 B colon 3 2
through 4 was
repealed lastly I'll just touch on a
couple things that came up in discussion
if I could um anticipating maybe I could
help answer a question that there Rose
earlier
um there's no intention on our part to
remove a local police department that
has the capacity to jail or confine
somebody there certainly was no
intention to remove that option or
resource if that occurred in the editing
of the bill that that was a a
mistake and the question uh I think
representative Roy asked could this
result in an increase in
charges I'm not really sure how that
would possibly happen
um what I said is true about a
protective custody old or somebody
that's presenting with charges if
there's a life-threatening medical
emergency we are not going to take
custody of them every one of our our
booking supervisor staff at the jails
are instructed in their judgment to not
take somebody if in their judgment that
person is potentially going to expire on
on our watch it's not in the current
statute for protective custodies
but it is in fact what happens on
occasion and as I said from that data
very
rarely I would admit there may be times
where there's not an agreement between
the police and the and the correctional
staff about when should somebody go up
the sheriff mentioned somebody who
smashed their head off the cage while
they're
intoxicated they're bleeding out they
need stitches
we don't have anyone in the facility to
give them stitches that's not
lifethreatening but honestly that's a
situation where we probably are going to
agree with the police and the correction
supervisor that person needs to get
stitched up come back to us and then we
will admit them whether they're under
facing criminal charges or protective
custody that disposition and that
screening process would look very very
much the
same I'm happy to take any questions you
might have thank
you so looking at the the part the first
part that you you um your main intention
of the bill with regards to Roman
3 as I said originally my reading of
that seems to be that all these things
here are provided or mandated so that
the person can be proved to be
definitely um
incapacitated in other words they won't
be held without actually proof of that
um I was looking at other states I
looked to at the state to our South in
in Massachusetts has no mention of any
of these things there's this very quick
simple it it would resemble ours if we
took that out for so do you let's just
speak to that to ensure that someone is
screened for intoxication in the first
place do you perform or do your
facilities perform any kind of sobriety
check when when an officer brings
someone for protective custody do you
have breathalyzers there to check their
we do have
breathalyzers but to be honest we do not
always use the
breathalyzers we're really going off of
the the officer on the streets judgment
their description of what's happened and
our own observations of that person's
behavior and a significant change from
1989 when I think the last edit happened
to this language we are not talking
about alcohol all the time or nearly as
often and we don't have we we do have
impairment and intoxication and
incapacitation based on drugs and a
significant change in the landscape of
of what's being used out there so a
certain percentage of the time it's not
about alcohol
anyway which raises an interesting
question so when someone comes in and
they appear to be perhaps under the
influence of opioids fentanyl whatever
what have you what is the procedure when
someone presents like that um for
protective custody um what do you do do
you just hold them and watch them do you
um do you administer an Naran what
happens if they're need of Naran and and
at risk of you know severe withdrawal
then we have an Ouran and we would
administer it um but we we observe them
directly and we do have a better
capacity than the officer on the street
for those basic
observations for use of a holding cell
for someone who's
uncooperative
um we don't have a better capacity in
many cases for medical screening though
but we will hold them and we can hold
them up to 24 hours but if we can find a
responsible adult the person's agreeable
to leave with them and that responsible
third party will take care of them
they're not charged
criminally they'll leave the facility at
that point again barring any sense of a
of a medical emergency uh that's going
on representative um selig and then Muse
thank you very much and thank you for
taking my question um
everything that I'm reading in this is
about releasing someone to the custody
of a competent adult and I I guess where
I'm maybe and this is maybe my own lack
of understanding of things but if the
person sobers up do they get released to
their own custody I mean like do
they what happens when the person you
know maybe is no longer Under the
Influence or uh whatever issue was
causing them to be incompetent has been
um
cleared up that's a good question um in
some percentage of cases uh we can't
find a sober responsible adult can't
reach them or they're not willing to
come that's a situation where we're more
likely to take some more time to ensure
that they're not no longer intoxicated
or incapacitated at a level that's
unsafe and in that case we will
transport them out of the facility to a
a safe location or to to home so it is
not necessary uh to always have a third
party come and pick them
up representa
Muse I wanted to focus a little bit on
the uh kind of back on the on the on the
bill itself so one of the things that we
heard is there are
concerns um that um the bill might be
perceived as a mandate uh for police
officers uh to use their judgment to
transport people to a medical facility
in the event in the event of a
life-threatening situation um
if it would seem that in the event of a
real lifethreatening situation most
police officers would transport somebody
directly or call for an ambulance um I
mean is as I read the statute and and
tell me if I'm wrong what it looks like
the bill does is it actually gives
police officer discretion um to either
take people directly to an ER uh or to
take people uh to the county jail but it
also looks like you have the discretion
um to make the same decision so so for
instance if in your judgment you believe
that the uh that the person is in a
life-threatening situation you can be
they you can transport them now I guess
my question is um in the event that
happens uh and the police officer has
left I'm assuming that the county would
then uh be responsible for the transport
or or would just simply call an
ambulance for the
person it if it was lifethreatening in
the way that we're describing in the
language of the bill we would be calling
an
ambulance
um but it but nothing changes the
discretion of the officer on the street
to to bring the person to a hospital or
call an ambulance and I'm sure in many
cases that is what
happens sometimes at the point between
putting the person in a cruiser and
getting to the jail their condition can
change especially with drugs and Drug
overdoses there have been some
instances where I think appropriately in
the uh officer's discre on the street
person was not at risk but arrives at
the facility and their their health
their status has changed perhaps an
example an
overdose um again it's half a perc of
our total bookings that we divert
somebody to a hospital it's not very
common and nothing in Our intention of
the language is to take away anybody's
judge judement neither the the police
officer's judgment about how to
dispose the best disposition of of that
detainee or at our receiving
end and I again will tell you that all
of our booking commanders are instructed
to never accept somebody into our
custody if you believe they are in a
truly lifethreatening
situation I would rather take the
liability of refusing somebody a in an
argument and and again I don't think in
those cases we are in an argument with
the the police in a life
life-threatening
situation but that's what happens now
it's just not been in statute and we
wanted it in there
but thank
you for hold on for clarification a
though so
if if someone arrives let's say they um
it was for what you said for fentel and
while in transport they go into OD and
they're
out it's not it's not like um the
corrections in law enforcement are
playing hot potato with the per
somebody's calling ambulance at that
point because the cruiser is not um
equipped to transport medically uh
people either so at that point
everything stops and and ambulance is
called is that correct correct that
would be correct okay thank you um
representative Stone thank you and thank
you for taking my
question under the current system and
quite conceivably as a practical matter
isn't the Department of Corrections on
the county level the best place to get
an individual since we've heard there
have been instances of being highly
combative uh it could be a mix of
alcohol and or drugs on board or I'm
sure you dealt with some people that
have outright refused to cooperate all
overall isn't that the safest for the
public as well as the officers involved
to get the individual to a place that's
secure with care custody and control
absolutely and nothing in this bill
would change that from happening thank
you representative
Newman thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question and I apologize if
you may have commented on this but I'm
curious as to in the current uh SE law
uh the removal of section four and
that's the part that says the jail or
County shall not refuse to admit
intoxicated person
Etc it still remains in there uh after
medical clearance um so it includes that
condition now that a a having a
life-threatening medical emergency
cleared at the hospital and then the
language that still exists immediately
after that section uh
states that the I don't have it in front
of me but the jail will um it says they
can't refuse after they will then admit
the local jail or County Correctional
Facility shall then admit the
person thank you I just had a hard time
finding that thank you very represent
Pro um perhaps I can add a little
clarification as being a town that lives
uh that is next to the Rockingham County
facility uh I have on a number of
occasions met up with a cruiser to take
a patient who went South on them while
transporting to the jail and also have
ended up at the booking office of the
jail to get patients who were determined
shouldn't be in there at the moment
needed to go to the hospital so that
practice does happen somebody calls an
ambulance for these people and we take
them to get they're screening and get
medically
cleared any further questions seeing
none thank you for your testimony thank
you the chair
calls Dustin
parent
my name is dtin parent been a full-time
police officer for 21 years uh hold the
rank of Captain at Guilford PD been
there my entire career I'm here today to
speak on behalf of Chief Kelly and the
New Hampshire Chiefs of police uh I was
going to speak on basically everything
that sheriff Wright discussed I don't
think that my redundancy is going to do
the the committee any justice and I'll
save you that I suppose so uh I I am in
opposition to House Bill 1270 dfn I will
just speak what I can more personally
and intelligently on which would be uh
the
section speaking
about potentially life-threatening
medical emergencies which seems to be
where we just left off anyway uh and I
and I agree with representative PR uh
that that does happen the ambulance does
need to be called at times I think that
confusing a police cruiser and a police
officer with with trained medical
personnel is is definitely a mistake so
we have the venue of Bank in Hampshire
Pavilion in Guilford uh we're lucky we
we'll say we have approximately 400
protective custody cases a year that
come out of there so I don't know what
other agencies statistics are but I will
confidently Venture a guess that we if
not at the top of the state are very
close to that so we have a lot of
experience with this and we are having
some issues with regard to uh getting
turned away at the jail so we we like to
hold our training accountable that we're
able to determine if a person in fact
does have a life-threatening medical
emergency that we would not be bringing
them up to the jail jail to begin with
and should they bring them up to the
jail then we would have a different
problem at our hands which would be
training and morals and ethics of that
particular officer at hand so uh that is
that is certainly not something that we
foresee being an issue but allowing that
to be again redundant to say the police
officer is going to determine whether or
not this individual has a
life-threatening Med medical emergency
and then another person I.E the Jailer
at the correctional facility then
confirming or not confirming whatever
that person's opinion might be is is
where we're going to run into our issues
so we we have staffing issues like
anyone else does we have to have
approximately anywhere from 16 to 20
officers per show and I speak solely on
on Meadowbrook or Bank in the Hampshire
Pavilion but understand we have bike
week and we have the gun stock ski area
we have the hill climbs that are in our
in our town so there's a lot of
different events it's just that the bank
and the Hampshire Pavilion carries the
most amount of work in quantity of these
types of cases so I'll refer to that
throughout uh so our issue being if
we're going to uh continue to rely on
the redundancy of the jailers to turn us
away it incurs a a significant cost to
us as well and we're not able to get our
people back at the venue and and to keep
in mind these people have already been
evaluated should they show any signs of
needing medical attention whatsoever
there's paramedics 24 hours in our town
in most towns that surround us I can't
speak to the rest of the State uh but
certainly at the venue there's
paramedics on scene they're detailed to
that particular venue so they've already
been cleared and if they speak anything
about having done drugs or ingested
drugs at any point in time during the
day we're getting told to get medical
clearance even though there's no sign of
uh life-threatening medical emergency um
I did hear you representative Roy ask
what what type of um protocol do you go
through with regard to determining if
somebody is impaired so everything that
we do at the Guilford Police Department
is on body warn cameras those also
closed circuit uh monitoring throughout
the whole venue so uh we have policies
in place that we do standardized field
sobriety testing we offer preliminary
breath tests to these people and that's
after observations such as physical
observations are are had of the person
to determine if they're impaired odor
things like that comprise and then lead
us to the direction of this person's
impaired due to alcohol drugs whatever
it might be and that decision is then
made we do our due diligence as does I I
speak confidently that all law
enforcement does their due diligence to
find a sober party for this person
because we don't want to drive them to
the jail we don't want to end up there
and take that person off the road um I
know I alluded to the bank in the
Hampshire Pavilion we have several
officers which still isn't enough I I
hope you you can trust me in that but
the people on the road working a
midnight shift might have one or two
officers on duty and then taking them
off the road can also pose a problem for
Community safety having them sitting in
a
hospital so as I said I my main concern
yes I think all of it carries the same
amount of weight that sheriff Wright
spoke on I just wanted to speak more
pointedly to this this particular
section as I think I have some
experience in that
area thank you with regards so let's
let's stick with your example um you
you've got an event going on at Pavilion
a concert you have a lot of intoxicated
people
so the officers you have there are on
detail right so they don't have Cruisers
they can't transport it's up to the is
it up to the the on Duty Officers to
handle the transports or how does it how
does that work as far as tying people up
yeah that's a good question so we they
are on detail um and just to kind of
just a quick synopsis so regular Patrol
as opposed to being on detail means that
the the venue themselves Bank in the
Hampshire Pavilion hires the police
officers the police department to be
there so they're not responsible for
handling calls throughout the community
during that time so part of that detail
is that there's a transport van or two
or three at the venue and then the
officers that are there for the detail
would be designated by the supervisor to
then take them to the jail should it be
should it be time if you will so we have
a probably three or four people could be
held on it's not made to hold people
obviously for long periods of time but
we have about a facility that'll hold
three or four people per cell and
there's two cells that are there pending
that they're not combative or male
female juvenile obviously there's
there's laws that that prohib us from
doing that so uh the short to your
answer is those people get transported
by the detail that are at that venue so
as a followup I if they get turned away
or any number of them get turned away um
who gets to go take them to the hospital
then is it the detail officer still are
they getting paid detail rates does the
Bank of New Hampshire agree with paying
excuse me the New Hampshire Pavilion pay
for all those hours yeah so in the
example of being turned away at during a
concert by one of the detail officers
that was doing the transporting they
would it would be them we can't
we wouldn't be tying up our Patrol units
we're just too busy for that so the
detail officer would then have to go to
the hospital at which point in time we
lose our transport van and then we lose
that officer that uh that we we really
can't afford to lose to begin with so
we're not asking the jail to do
something or take on a
responsibility that that isn't
unreasonable we're we're simply saying
to trust us in our ability to evaluate
the person and the paramedics that are
on scene to evaluate the the person to
determine if it is in fact a
life-threatening issue or emergency that
we would have brought him to the
hospital to begin with OR allowed the on
duty ambulance to transport them and not
tie up our officers that already
determined that they were fine to go to
jail are you familiar with um
172b col 3 the protective custody
statute I don't have that in front of me
but okay try me uh well I was going to
ask with regard to uh with regard to
Roman 3 that says no person shall be
lodged in a jiler County Correction
Facility under paragraph two unless the
person charges immediately upon lodging
said person protective custody contacts
a designated alcohol counselor clinical
staff person approved alcohol treatment
program detox case it goes on and on and
it culminates in the point of that um
that all those people are to determine
whether or not said person is indeed
incapacitated and then it says if an
only if none of the forgoing are
available such medical clinician
determined shall be made by a registered
nurse apparently they don't have those
either so is it your would you agree
with my interpretation that this was put
in there as a as some type of protection
for a citizen to prove that they are
indeed
intoxicated
it I can't speak to
the how what the intent was but I will I
will agree with you that that's it makes
a lot of Hoops and what is your opinion
if we would just to strike that
paragraph I I think that the manner in
which we've been doing business
by taking care of the
public making sure that we're not doing
anything out of malice which I have
never witnessed fortunately that I think
that we were we were doing things
properly to begin with well you're
already given field sobriety tests and
you are from a preliminary breath test
is that's right that's correct um and it
no one's barred from um bringing a cause
of action against the police department
for false arrest if they can prove they
weren intoxicated if they have friends
or Witnesses I mean they're free to
bring that is that true that that is
true and I have been on the other end of
those complaints multiple times and I
alluded to uh earlier when I was
testifying that our body worn cameras
our J our U booking facility is all
videotaped so those types of things are
what we fall back on to ensure that our
policies are followed with regard to
offer ing standardized field sobriety
tests and preliminary breath tests thank
you representative Newman it's just just
a question of the chair that that
section that you read section three and
B3 isn't that repealed by the by the
language on the L on line on page one
line 23 it is but the bill also adds a
bunch of other things that aren't
Germain and the um the the
superintendent said that this is the
thing that were most important so I was
curious as to the effect of law
enforcement but I just wanted to make
sure that that this takes that out okay
thank you representative Manion thank
you Mr chair this is not really a
question for the uh for the officer but
you made a statement earlier about the
detail and who would be
responsible every agency is different I
know the agencies that I've worked for
the detail officer stays at the detail a
patrol officer would come and handle the
call and transport the person um and I
guess the thing is a people are paying
for detail if all three of them are gone
now nobody's covering that facility for
the night so we have some times where
there's one officer on the detail and he
can't leave well I I'm I'm aware that
detail pay is is is higher than a normal
salary and if an officer's on detail for
you and then they're tied up at a
hospital for 14 hours in an emergency
room who pays for that the person might
say I'm not paying that that's not what
I hire you to do representative
s thank you and thank you for taking my
question um
um I'm curious if there's um just in
your experiences in Guilford with the
concerts and the various events in that
area um whether there's impact of um
people who are under the influence of
hallucinogenics that need to go into
protective custody for their own safety
to some degree as well or if there's an
impact from that so you're asking do we
do we come across people that are
impaired from narcotics not just alcoh
I I'm sure you come across people who
are impaired from narcotics but we last
year heard a lot of testimony about
people wanting us to decriminalize
various forms of hallucinogenics and
having um I I don't remember the term
they use but basically sessions where
they bring people in to give lots I
don't remember the name of the anyway
drugs that are similar to LSD except
maybe created differently and so I I
wasn't sure whether you have been seeing
impact of people
under the influence of things like that
um absolutely in a noticeable way have
you picked up a lot of people on shrooms
we we we yes and they and to be honest
with you a lot of people probably what
you would think is to the opposite is
they admit it to us they a lot of these
people tell us because they're scared
when this starts to happen to them to
their body and they and they tell us and
they're given medical treatment at that
time we like I said we have paramedics
on scene and then Andor if they need to
be transported to the
hospital is your agency accredited we
are not accredited okay do in your
understanding are many of the
Departments are accredited across the
state do do the accreditation standards
or even your department policies speak
to what you do if you encounter someone
regardless of it's a PC or an arrest and
they have a visible injury um it does
what's the first thing that's to be done
with them I'm actually
ironically I am the one that is handling
our accreditation process through the
state the state is as you probably know
is going to be offering that so yes we
do have a policy that speaks to that and
they immediately are offered and
afforded medical attention and that's
prior to bringing them to their
destination be it to a friend's house or
to jail yes they're they're afforded
medical attention prior to going to the
jail should they need it thank you
representative Manion thank you Mr chair
and thank you uh for taking question
actually it's more for clarification
this law currently as it stands in the
bill only apply to alcohol intoxication
correct not drugs correct I so
everyone's on the same page with it
correct okay thank you I I did have one
more point that I had heard throughout
the testimony here today and uh it was
with regard to the condition
worsening um prior contact to with the
officer having evaluated that person the
officer evaluates decides this person is
ultimately going to be uh getting PCD
and then the condition worsens in the
cruiser and that's the ability to turn
them away I I speak on behalf of the
Guilford Police Department that we do
the exact protocol that representative
PR alluded to we would not then be
turned away and transport them we would
be saying well we need to call an
ambulance at this time so should that
that um situation worsen and then
becomes potential overdose or
life-threatening injury or something
like that we we wouldn't then be
transporting we would be going with an
ambulance so the the language doesn't
really support what our actions would
be if in the middle of Transport you
look in the rear view mirror and your
transport's killed over do you divert to
an emergency room or do you pull over
and administer first aid and call an
ambulance that b thank
you represent n thank you and thank you
for taking my question yes um you
mentioned that there has been concern or
there have been instances where uh
people are being turned away um from
Correctional Facilities right and so uh
you know another thing that you
mentioned was you know to trust your
judgment right what this seems to do in
my mind is is it says either um the
superintendent or uh the peace officer
um it would be either one of their
judgment right and so what I'm wondering
is when they're being turned away as
you've seen recently is it a difference
between um their judgment you know what
I mean is is it um is the feeling that
they're unnecessarily being turned away
yeah that's a good question and I I I
believe I know predominantly there are
going to be various other instances
where the Turning Away could have taken
place however it's a lot of it is airing
on the side of caution when the person
says that they've ingested some type of
narcotic at some point during the day
then that that person the the jailers
are airing on the side of caution okay
get them medically cleared even though
there aren't any signs of needing an
life or having a life-threatening
medical emergency can I follow up really
quickly um thank you um an um I'm I'm
curious about the idea of uh someone
coming in who is intoxicated in one way
or another um whether it's alcohol or
drugs or something like that um and the
ability um of having someone in the in
the facility
versus in in a an emergency room um of
the ability of that person to be able to
um receive you know medication assisted
treatment or you know something like
that that would help them um to um that
would improve their chances of of um
recovery or something like that do you
think that there's you know better odds
of that being available at an emergency
room or in a correctional facility I I
can only speak to the county in which I
work so when asked with a a conversation
with staff superintendent in the county
in which I work the Staffing was a
problem so having the nurse on on duty
24 hours a day wasn't feasible for them
so that's why they were unable to do
their own evals whereas if it happened
during business hours we'll say and that
nurse was there then it was portrayed to
us that that evaluation would then take
place at that time and if not then the
police will be deemed with that
responsibility to uh take them to the
hospital and be turned away ultimately
thank
you no further question represent Stone
thank you and real quickly thank you for
taking my question uh in the case of you
you Lodge somebody as a PC at say belnap
County and uh within an hour an
ambulance is dispatched who ends up
providing the security coverage for that
individual when they are sent to the
hospital I'm going to say I don't know
with that said I'm confident that it's
going to be the Laconia Police
Department because that's the
jurisdiction in which that the jail uh
is located but I say that only based on
I guess using my my common sense to it
because the jail isn't isn't trained to
do that um to more answer to answer that
more directly on behalf of the Guilford
Police we have never been called to go
back and provide that security for the
ambulance only leaving lonia PD to be
the ones to do so thank
you thank you for your testimony thank
you is there anyone else wishing to
testify on this bill seeing none I
hereby close the public hearing we'll be
back Friday
morning